Mokka W
Easy.
Monka W.
Monka S.
x-beck
heute probieren wir das ukrainers aus mit tuners ich glaube nicht dass mich schon das überzeugt das
letzte mal wo ich mir das angeguckt aber es mir nicht so gut gefallen aber ihr habt ja schon
öfters gesagt da hat sich einiges getan angeblich soll auch die ganze
virtualisierung und container verwaltung viel besser sein als zu dem zeitpunkt
wo ich mir das angeguckt habe weil er sich mir das letzte mal angeguckt habe
da war das noch auf irgendeiner komischen kuba nietes single note
geschichte basierend bär metal ich habe es noch nicht mal ausgepackt
ich muss gleich das nass auspacken netzteil auspacken hier alles anschließen
aber ohne kamera weil viel zu gucken gibt es da nicht wenn es taugt gucken
wir uns dann auch noch mal zusammen an wie das nass im drin aussieht wenn man
aufmacht und so die line dankeschön für den sub 25 monate massive subscription
er aktuell aktuell habe ich drei neue da und mein mein aktuelles also man aktuelles was ich
jetzt gerade noch im einsatz hat ist ja noch ein hp microserver gab es ein
inzident aber das ist eine gute sache ich habe schon eine weile nicht aufs
handy geguckt vielleicht habe ich ja überhört
hinter krieg ich auf jeden fall mit nix nix nix ich guck mal gerade ins teams
ob noch irgendeiner geschrieben hat aber das hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch an
notification gekriegt
Nee, sieht nicht so aus.
Nee, nee.
Muss mal E-Mails gucken, ob irgendwas Spannendes war.
Nö, nix.
Dann lege ich das Handy jetzt hier einfach mal hin,
dass ich mitkriege, sollte es irgendwie ein Inzidenz geben
oder irgendeine Monitoring-Alarmierung.
kriege ich das mit dann muss ich stream ausmachen aber ich gehe nicht davon aus
dass irgendwas ist ganz ehrlich glaube ich nicht
wie das brauchen wir nicht wie gesagt ich muss ja nichts machen ich muss
müsste müsste ja nur was machen wenn irgendwie irgendwelche produktiv sachen
die den nötigen das nötige ist aber wichtigkeit level haben jetzt irgendwie ausfallen ansonsten
ist das egal was ist der unterschied zu einem sein oligien das bsp ist deutlich besseres preis
leistungsverhältnis sein oligie hat ja ziemlich lahme hardware für den preis drücken was man so
aus was ein oligie natürlich hat ist die software das sind ja viele große fans dieses quasi dass
des Softwarepakets, was es damit gibt.
Was würdet ihr empfehlen?
Das alte System auf dem NAS
per Clone...
Ups, jetzt ist gerade eine Seite
von meinem
Headset ausgegangen.
Was ist das denn? Wartet mal kurz.
Okay.
Okay, jetzt geht es wieder.
Keine Ahnung, was das gewesen ist.
Würde dir empfehlen, das alte System auf dem Raspberry Clon Zilla zu klonen und dir
irgendwo als Image wegzulegen?
Wenn man mal das alte System wieder drauf machen will, muss man den Support anschreiben.
Aha, Moment, das gibt es nicht zum Download.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt gleich mal angucken.
Ich starte mal kurz hier meine Linux Kiste.
Mal gucken, gibt es da wirklich nichts zum Download?
Machen wir mal kurz hier Mini-PC an, Tastatur anstöpseln kurz.
das ist übrigens das was also ich werde das selbst wenn mir das gut gefällt werde ich
das nicht verwenden das kriegt einer meiner mod ist das nass ich behalte das minis forum
das gefällt mir von der hardware zumindest jetzt noch besser aber es bietet sich an das
mal auszuprobieren zumindest sollten wir mit dem mit ich bin wir müssen uns müssen dann auch gleich
mal netzwerk performance angucken ich könnte wetten bei dem ukrainers die
netzwerk performance etwas konstanter als bei dem mini forum wofür braucht man
ein dass wenn du sachen haben willst auf dem netzwerk share backups oder falls
sie in den netzwerk share auf mehreren rechner haben willst so whatever also
also das ist nur die durch die storage die storage geschichte ansonsten ist das
ein stinknormaler server ja kannst du container drauf laufen lassen ganze
vor allem darauf laufen lassen du musst das nass ja noch nicht immer wirklich als netzwerk storage
hauptsächlich verändern so da sind wir wieder hier beim zack hoch so firefox öffnen dachte
das verdammte Spiel.
Terminal öffnen.
Erstmal Updates machen.
Ganz wichtig.
Massive Update.
Wenn mein System älter als eine Viertelstunde ist,
das geht nicht.
Das ist mir dann nicht Bleeding Edge genug.
Hier gibt es keine Updates.
Da gibt es keine Updates.
Da gibt es System-Updates.
Aber kein Kernel-Update.
Oh, doch, Kernel-Update.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt
rebooten.
Scheiß drauf.
Nächstes Mal, wenn ich das Ding stoppe, dann passt das schon.
Ich reboot jetzt. Ich habe keinen Bock zu rebooten.
Also, ich habe...
Aktuell habe ich ja drei Nasses am Start daheim zum Ausprobieren.
Warum?
Weil es mir danach war.
So.
Ich habe einmal ein Minisforum.
Ich habe einmal das Ding hier zum Ausprobieren.
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nutzen.
Minisforum N5 Luft.
Dann habe ich, als erstes habe ich mir einen Ugreen Nuss gekauft, nämlich ein, ich habe mir ursprünglich einen Ugreen 4800 Plus gekauft und dann nach ein paar Wochen kam das 4800 Pro raus, das habe ich mir auch noch gekauft.
Also eine Runde, eine Runde hier, Pepo Burn Money.
So, und jetzt habe ich das Ding hier am Start.
Und das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ich wollte mir nämlich E-Tru-NAS angucken.
Und da kann ich das einfach 1 zu 1 nehmen.
So wie es ist.
Ich werde die SSD drinnen lassen.
Man kann das einfach als Homesurfer füllen.
Klar, das ist ja kein Unterschied.
Eine NAS ist ganz normale Hardware, wie bei allem anderen Kram auch.
Also bloß, dass du bei einem NAS in der Regel vorne noch so Wechselrahmen drin hast.
Aber ansonsten ist das überhaupt kein Unterschied.
Also ich werde die interne SSD benutzen, um TrueNAS zu installieren.
Dann stöpsel ich eine olle Festplatte rein und eine olle SSD per SATA.
sata und dann basteln wir ein bisschen rum mit dem zeug was schulers so kann
kommen wir uns an ob tunas nice ist oder ob tunas sagt
muss man da mal gucken ich tippe ja drauf dass tunas nicht
sacken wird aber es wird trotzdem nicht gefällt so das ist so meine meine
vermutung bei der ganzen geschichte
Wir können uns mal kurz die Hardware von dem Ding hier angucken, bevor ich es auspacke.
Also im Vergleich zu Minis Forum NAS hat das nur 4 Einschübe für SATA Platten und SATA
SSDs.
Was ist dein Favorit bis jetzt?
Aktuell verwende ich Unraid.
So richtig happy war ich mit Unraid aber auch nicht.
jetzt werde ich Broxmox verwenden
auf dem Minisforum Nass
ob ich damit dann so richtig happy bin
weiß ich auch nicht
es gibt irgendwie nix was mich so richtig happy
macht so an
an so
Consumer
Nass System
ich persönlich ganz ehrlich
ich bin ja immer noch Fan von einfach Debian drauf installieren
und alles selbst machen
aber manchmal ist ein gescheites UI
und ein paar Sachen, die schon vorkonfiguriert sind,
auch nicht so verkehrt,
weil das hier soll ja kein zweiter Job werden,
sondern es soll im Prinzip einfach nur
möglichst problemfrei im Hintergrund laufen,
ohne dass ich überhaupt merke, dass es da ist.
Was muss es denn haben, damit du happy wirst?
Ich, ja, das kann ich dir so gar nicht
in einzelnen Punkten sagen.
Es muss sich für mich einfach
in einem guten System anfühlen.
so und das, also
ich kann es mal am Beispiel von Unraid machen
ja, also
Unraid, was mir bei Unraid gefällt
was mir bei Unraid gefällt, ist das
wie sie die
das Diskhandling implementiert haben
also dass du unterschiedlich große Platten
benutzen kannst, dass du eine SSD
Cache benutzen kannst
das ist alles relativ easy gemacht
das finde ich richtig gut bei Unraid
die
das VM und Docker Handling bei Unraid
ist allerdings ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig ja also dass das
ui wie 15 jahre alt und ist irgendwie hakelig auf der anderen seite ganz
ernst man kann einfach auch eine vm darauf starten und darauf irgendwie doch
neu oder docker compose oder meint wie auch kubernetes oder was auch immer
machen muss ja dass docker frontend nicht verwenden aber wenn es ist schon
ganz nah ist also das gefällt weder auf das vm handling noch das kommt docker
Containerhandling gefällt mir auf Android sonderlich gut.
Was mir bei Android auch nicht gefällt, ist,
dass es auf Slackware-Basis ist.
So ein vollständiges Debian oder so
unten drunter wird mir persönlich viel besser gefallen.
Kann man auch mehr machen mit.
Ja, und ansonsten
gibt es sicherlich noch einige Sachen, die
ich gut und schlecht finde.
Müsste ich mir jetzt mal ein bisschen länger Gedanken drüber machen.
So.
Sind die 144 TB Platten dabei?
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee.
Steht doch sogar extra da.
Nee.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn da 144 TB Platten dabei wären,
dann würde ich mir ganz viele kaufen für 699 Euro
und hätte Infinite Money Klitsch,
indem ich da einfach die Platten ausbaue und die Platten verkaufe.
Nee, nee, nee.
Also das Einzige, was dabei ist, ist eine SSD.
Eine, aber keine gute SSD.
eine interne, frag mich nicht
64 Gig oder so
SSD, intern
ja
und das war's
und 8G RAM glaube ich, ich glaube 8G
RAM sind dabei, man kann
aber bis zu 96 einbauen
also Hardware
Hardware mäßig
finde ich
das Minis Forum
das deutlich
innovativer könnte man vielleicht sagen oder besser ausgestattet trifft eigentlich ganz gut
ja innovativer und besser ausgestattet aber ich glaube was treiber support und alles angeht ist
das ukraine etwas besser ich war in minis forum hat sich jetzt schon öfters paar dinge geleistet
beispielsweise beim n5 pro das gibt es ja auch noch da war der sata controller kaputt da muss
du irgendwelche komischen kölner parameter angeben beim guten sonst hast du das file system corrupted
mit der zeit also und außerdem ist mini forum auch nicht dafür bekannt jetzt regelmäßig bios
updates rauszuhauen und sowas mini forum release tausende geräte und supportet nichts richtig davon
also von der hardware ist das halt viel besser du hast du hast fünf disk einschübe du hast du
gar einen okulink du hast ein deutlich mehr cpu power mit dem reisen du hast
eine pc express dort du hast drei frei zugängliche nvme slots also von der
hardware ist das cooler insgesamt wenn es einfach nur auf treiber support
stable betrieb ankommt und sowas und man die anderen sachen nicht so sehr braucht
vermute ich jetzt einfach ohne dass ich bis jetzt ausprobiert habe deswegen war
das ja heute dass man wahrscheinlich mit dem ukraine besser fährt
ich hab's auch proxmox drauf auf dem jetzt machen wir tuners drauf auf dem
minis forum ist proxmox drauf das funktioniert auch ganz gut das was mich
hat bei den minis forum das übelst abfuckt sind dass ich aus irgendwelchen
gründen ab und zu richtig miese also richtig miese nvm ssd performance
habe normalerweise haben die ssds die flutschen ja wenn ich damit vier ohne
benchmark mache selbst wenn der cash aufgebraucht ist von den ssds habe ich
immer noch 1200 megabytes die sekunde 1,2 gig das vollkommen fein ja also wie
gesagt wenn der nach 120 gig oder so ist irgendwie der der slc cash aufgebraucht
das ist immer noch schnell aber manchmal ist es richtig lahm aus mir nicht
nachvollziehbaren gründen haben die dinger dann nur 4 500 mb die sekunde und
Andere Mal Wieder sind sie super schnell Für die gesamte kopie operation Keine ahnung was mit dem minis forum die stimmt und die
Netzwerkkarte Die Netzwerkkarte Bei Den Minis forum Kann man nicht anders Sagen ist Kompletter
Wie gesagt Bei dem n5 er
Die Haben Ja noch andere die haben Ja noch ich Kann das gerade Mal zeigen wir mal das
Mal ein bisschen vergleich bevor ich das ding auspacke
also die hier dass das n5 er hat eine hat das ding hier irgendwie so eine
Äh, hallo?
Hat das vielleicht irgendwie so Hardware-Overview oder sowas irgendwo?
A Pro Gamers Lab?
Was auch immer das das mit Pro Gaming zu tun hat.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was Minis Forum mir damit sagen möchte.
Hat das Ding hier nicht irgendwie eine ordentliche Hardware-Übersicht?
Irgendwo da?
So, vielleicht?
Wir können uns den Unterschied angucken, genau.
Ja, also hier sieht man den Unterschied ganz gut.
Also das N5 Pro ist das, was SATA-Controller-Probleme hat.
Ich kann euch das zeigen.
Also wenn ihr jetzt sagt, ey Max, was laberst du da für Zeug?
SATA Corruption gibt es hier.
Silent Data Corruption on N5 Pro
NAS. Da muss man
irgendwelche kryptischen
Kernel-Parameter setzen, dass man die Probleme nicht hat.
Also da gibt es mit dem N5 Pro
gibt es auch ordentlich
Issues.
Und soweit ich das gesehen habe,
hat bis jetzt
Miniforum noch kein Firmware-Update
veröffentlicht, was das fixt.
Vielleicht ist es auch Controller-seitig und sie können es gar nicht
fixen.
Wir können mal gucken
Wir können mal gucken, ob die das mittlerweile gefixt haben
Ähm
Firmware
Was ist weniger schlimm, SATA oder Netzwerkprobleme?
Tja
Naja, in dem Fall würde ich sagen, sind die Netzwerkprobleme weniger schlimm
Weil die Netzwerkprobleme mit dem Herstellertreiber
Sind ja nur
Ein bisschen
zu niedrige Performance
von
der 10 Gig Netzwerkkarte.
Also anstatt 9,5 Gig
packt die halt nur
8,8 Gig oder so.
Ja.
Also.
Guck mal, es gibt noch nicht mal eine Seite hier
für den Kram.
Hier.
Kannst du knicken.
N5, suchen wir mal.
N5 Luft.
Ich finde es immer noch geil, dass die N5 Air mit Luft übersetzen.
Hier, Treiber und Downloads.
BIOS. Aha, die haben BIOS veröffentlicht.
Von, Moment, das lädt direkt runter.
Äh, okay.
Weiß man nicht, wann das veröffentlicht wurde.
Gucken wir mal.
Ähm.
2000...
Okay, hier.
Das ist noch das alte BIOS.
13.06.25.
Da gab es kein neues BIOS.
Also, Minisforum ist auch wirklich nicht bekannt dafür, ihre Produkte gut zu supporten.
So, aber heute geht es hier um das Ugreenast.
Also wir können uns das mal angucken, was das hier hat.
Das alte.
Warte mal, ich zeige euch mal den Vergleich.
Hier, so.
Die zwei habe ich von Ugreen.
Ich habe einen 4800+.
4800 plus das ist das allererste was was ich mir dieses jahr gekauft habe das war eigentlich geplant als ablöse von meinem
hp microserver
Das hatte ich auch schon ausgepackt eingerichtet und dachte ich kann es nice und dann haben
das 1 5 pro raus
da dachte ich mir das probierst jetzt auch noch mal aus und dann kam das minis forum in 5 er raus
und dachte ich mir das probierst jetzt auch noch aus
und jetzt habe ich drei nasses ich werde folgendermaßen machen dass ein fünf pro kriegt
kriegt der max mod gemacht kriegt das und das plus behalte ich entweder für irgendeine anwendung die
die sich eventuell noch bei mir ergibt oder das kriegt random einer aus dem chat weil
Danke schön für den Sub.
Und das hier wird mein neuer Main-Server im Endeffekt.
Hardware-mäßig ist das...
Ne, Moment, sorry. Das ist das falsche.
Das ist das falsche Nass.
Das hier. Das N5R wird mein neues.
Mein neuer Main-Server hier.
Das Ding hat wirklich
richtig gute...
Warte mal hier. Spezifikationen.
Äh.
Okay.
Minis Forum Omega Lul.
Also das hat wirklich richtig gute Hardware drinnen.
Was bei dem problematisch ist, wo ich gerade ein bisschen geflamed habe, die Netzwerkkarte.
Die Netzwerkkarte ist wirklich shit, die hier.
Die ist wirklich absoluter Müll.
das ist eine real tech 8000 also rtl 81 27
wieso brauchst du dir nicht ein nass mit dreifacher leistung statt 3 nass weil
schwierig ist was zu bauen was performance mäßig und eitel
stromverbrauch mäßig dahin kommen preis leistungsmäßig sind die gut warum ich
drei habe ist reine bastel basteltrieb das ist nichts was man irgendwie
rational mit weil sich lohnt erklären könnte
das allererste dieses jahr richtig aber ich habe mir auch schon lange keine
hardware mehr gekauft deswegen war mal wieder zeit so zumindest diese
netzwerkkarte ist wirklich schrott die rtl 8127 das problem ist es gibt es also
erste mal problem ist die netzwerkkarte ist ziemlich neu
linux kornel treiber support gibt es erst seit 6 15 also karl version 6 15
Beispielsweise TrueNAS hat in der aktuellen Version überhaupt gar keinen Treiber für diese Netzwerkkarte drin.
So, das nächste Problem ist, dass der Treiber...
Naja, der Treiber ist ziemlicher Müll, der im Kernel ist.
Weil, ich kann euch das zeigen, also aus mehreren Gründen ist der Treiber Müll.
Erstens von dem, dass er nicht richtig funktioniert bei Virtualisierung.
Das andere ist, und ich gehe davon aus, da ist Linux wahrscheinlich auch nicht so happy drüber über solche Treiber.
Ich zeige euch das mal hier.
GitHub.
GitHub Linux.
Wir gucken uns mal kurz hier Linux Source Code an.
Drivers.
Net.
Ethernet.
Und jetzt Realtek oder so?
Realtek?
Hier.
So.
Pass mal auf.
Der Treiber ist halt, im Endeffekt besteht der aus Magic.
Ja, der Treiber besteht im Endeffekt aus ganz viel Magic, auf irgendwelche Adressen irgendwelche Magic Bytes schreiben.
Also das ist kein Treiber, den du dir angucken kannst und dann weißt du, wie die Netzwerkkarte funktioniert.
Das ist einfach komplette Magic.
Ich kann euch mal das Comet zeigen.
Ähm
Warte mal, dafür müssen wir das
Dafür müssen wir das aber klonen
Ich klone mal kurz
Den
Linux-Source-Code
Das dauert ein paar Minuten, bis das geklont ist
Ne, ne, ne, ne
Ich will nicht mit Depth 1 klonen
Ich will mir ja die History angucken können
Das dauert jetzt kurz
Aber macht ja nichts
Oh, Chatterino ist noch nicht gestartet
Realtek Karten haben nicht den besten Ruf
zu Recht, habe ich jetzt gesehen
ja, ja, zu Recht
so, und also das
richtiges Problem, was ich mit dem Netzwerktreiber
habe, ist, der Treiber, der im
Kernel drin ist, wie gesagt, der ist auch noch ganz neu
6.15, der hat
Probleme bei Virtualisierung
also ansonsten ist die Performance echt ganz okay
aber
wenn man eine VM
benutzt und dort drüber darüber netzwerk bandbreite ja oder netzwerksachen
überträgt dann ist die bandbreite nur halb so hoch wie auf dem host und das
liegt nicht an der bridge oder sonst was es liegt am netzwerk treiber ich habe
das sogar nachvollzogen nicht nur bei mir mehrfach sogar mit dem chat hat
leute leute haben im chat haben das gleiche gerät die haben das auch
ausprobiert du bekommst in der vm mit dem embedded netzwerk treiber also für
dem im kernel drin der netzwerktreiber bekommst du nur fünf gig von zehn gig
performance so und da kommt jetzt als nächstes halt das ins spiel was ich euch
gezeigt habe dass der treiber im prinzip magic bites an irgendwelche speicher
adressen schreiben ist das heißt das kann auch niemand fixen außer realtec
selber und realtec selber hat keinen bock das zu fixen anscheinend was ist
ihr bei treibern wo man die sich ein bisschen durchkämpfen kann und vielleicht
verstehen kann wie die hardware funktioniert was der treiber macht hätte man da theoretisch also ich nicht ja
dafür kenne ich mich low level nicht genug mit netzwerkkarten aus und und linux treiber aber da könnte jemand hingehen
der sich damit auskennt und sagen okay ich guck mal woran es liegt und das fixen
bei diesem art von treiber bist du halt auf gedeih und verderben darauf angewiesen dass
das real tech irgendwas fixt weil der treiber eben aus magic bites besteht zu 90 prozent so
was man jetzt machen kann was man machen kann ist also wie gesagt bei diesen bei diesen minis
forum ding was man für den treiber hier machen kann ist man kann sich den treiber vom hersteller
herunterladen ja man kann hier auf die auf die real tech seite gehen sich den treiber vom
hersteller herunterladen die real tech seite übrigens auch eines der hässlichsten seiten
die ich je gesehen habe.
So, kann man sich hier runterladen
und installieren unter Linux.
Das Blöde ist halt,
was passiert bei dem Kernel-Update?
Dann ist der Treiber wieder weg.
Dementsprechend musst du dir
ein DKMS-Modul,
also DKMS-Config suchen.
DKMS ist so ein Ding,
ist für Kernel-Module.
Die werden automatisch neu gebaut,
wenn der Kernel geupdatet wird und sowas.
Da musst du dir quasi irgendeine DKMS-Config suchen,
suchen für den Netzwerk Treiber, dann musst du den Treiber noch drin aktualisieren und
so. Hab ich gemacht, funktioniert auch, aber ist halt nicht schön. Ja so richtig nice
ist das unter Linux eigentlich immer, wenn der Treiber im Kernel ist und wenn der Treiber
der im Kernel ist auch taugt. So und das ist bei dieser Realtek Netzwerkkarte nicht der
Fall. Der Treiber der im Kernel aktuell drin ist sackt und außer Realtek kann das auch
keiner fixen, weil der Treiber wie gesagt aus 90% Magic Bytes besteht. Also richtig
für den Arsch.
Pirate Software, all den Namen hab ich schon lange nicht mehr.
Hab ich nicht mehr gehört, seit ich zum Onlyfans,
äh, nicht Onlyfans, Onlyfangs-Drama.
Genau.
So, und das Vorteil vom Pro,
wie gesagt, das Pro würde ich nicht
empfehlen, ja, weil das Pro
kaputt nen SATA-Controller hat.
Der Vorteil vom Pro ist,
dass der eben ne andere Netzwerkkarte hat.
der hat eine 10 Gig Aquantik
Netzwerkkarte.
Äh.
Heißen die nicht Aquantik?
Aquantik?
Doch. Ne. Schwimmbäder?
Äh.
Aquantia, nicht Aquantik
Aquantia, wirklich?
Nee
Doch
Nicht Aquantik, ich sag immer Aquantik, das ist aber Blödsinn
Ja
Okay, und das gehört zu Marvel, alles klar
Zumindest da sind die Linux-Treiber
Wohl auch nicht die geilsten ever, aber die sind
deutlich besser als diese Realtek-Treiber.
So,
und jetzt kommen wir mal zum U-Creen-NAS, was wir
heute ausprobieren. Das hat
auch eine 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte,
also wir können uns gerade mal kurz die
Netzwerk-Config angucken.
Ne, ähm,
Melanox gehört zu Nvidia.
Aquantia bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob die zu
Nvidia gehören. Glaube ich nicht. Melanox gehört zu Nvidia.
Was sind Magic Bytes?
Zeige ich dir. Zeige ich dir gleich, sobald hier Linux
geklont ist. Okay, ist geklont.
Ich zeige dir, was ich meine.
Okay, gehen wir mal hier hin.
Ähm, Drivers
äh, Net
Ethernet Realtek
So, jetzt machen wir mal ein Git-Log
Auf
Schauen wir mal hier
Naja
Log-P
Guck, sowas hier meine ich
Das sind Magic Bytes
Das sind Bytes
Die werden an irgendeine Stelle geschrieben
Und die machen was
Keine Sau weiß, was das macht
Das weiß nur der Hersteller
Ups, ich hab mich verdrückt
Verstehst du, was ich meine?
Ja, man sieht das auch noch mehr
Wenn man hier durchscrollt
Hast du sehr viele Stellen
Hast du irgendwelche Magic Bytes
Wir hatten letztens auch
Ja, oder auch beispielsweise hier
Ne, das war es nicht
Moment
Wir haben doch letztens was Schönes gefunden.
Ähm, wartet mal.
Wir suchen mal.
Warte mal, geht lock.
Nach R8127.
Der Treiber ist komplett proprietär.
Da hat keiner eine Ahnung, wie das Ding funktioniert.
Ich finde das
kommet nicht.
Guck das hier.
Sowas hier meine ich.
Komplett Magic.
Du hast absolut keine Ahnung, wie die Hardware funktioniert.
Es werden an irgendwelche Stellen irgendwelche Bytes geschrieben.
Guck, das ganze Ding besteht daraus.
Also du hast zwar einen Treiber, der funktioniert,
aber du hast keine Ahnung, wie er funktioniert.
Obwohl es ein Open Source Treiber ist.
Letztendlich der Hersteller weiß halt,
Okay, schreib an diese Adresse diese Bytes rein.
Das macht dann irgendwas.
Das sagt dann, keine Ahnung, zum Beispiel, ja, Port Auto Negotiation soll auf Auto stehen oder sowas.
Heißt das dann?
Das weißt du nicht.
Ja, das ist keiner.
Sind nicht alle Treiber so?
Ne.
Ne, du könntest zum Beispiel, könntest du einen E-Nom machen.
Ja, wo dann drinnen steht, kannst du einen Inam machen, ja, zum Beispiel nennst du den dann, dass ich, Network, machen wir irgendwie sowas hier, hier, machen wir mal ein Beispiel, ja, hier, keine Ahnung, ich schleife hier irgendwie Inam, das ist jetzt nur ein Pseudo-Code, ne.
So, der Inam heißt, keine Ahnung, hier, NickConfig oder so
Und da hast du dann sowas wie PortSpeed
PortSpeed ist dann halt, keine Ahnung, 0x85blablub, irgendwas, ja
Dann hast du, was hat eine Netzwerkkarte sonst noch irgendwie
HW Offload oder sowas
So, das musst du dann an diese Adresse hier, so was könntest du schreiben und dann könntest du für die Magic, dann könntest du dann auch noch sagen, okay, I-Namen, Port, Speed und dann hast du sowas wie 1G, 5G, 10G.
1g ist dann halt aus irgendwelchen gründen dieser wert 5g ist dann aus
irgendwelchen gründen dieser wert oder was ja das kannst du machen dann ist
das ganze schon einmal deutlich sprechen da was überhaupt passiert weil weil wenn
du da einfach nur beiz reinschreibt hat keiner eine ahnung für was die beiz sind
das weiß letztendlich der hersteller kann es kann zu machen ja man kann das
man kann das auch beliebig noch kapseln ja man könnte auch irgendwelche stracks
machen mit mit mit mit mit toten drauf also man kann das schon durchaus
leserlicher machen wichtig ist jetzt nicht unbedingt dass es keine magic
bytes oder dass es keine bytes gibt die irgendwo hingeschrieben werden
letztendlich musst du das machen wenn du der hardware sagen willst macht das und
ist ja dann wird eine speicheradresse mit irgendein spezieller wert geschrieben
worauf dann halt die hardware weiß was sie machen soll
aber du kannst es halt ordentlich benennen und das ist da nicht das ist
halt wenn ihr euch sagen das ist komplette magic komplett du hast absolut kein platz
und schimmer was es macht so dass dementsprechend kann das auch nur wie tag anpassen wo man
chat gpt fragen ich kann ja gar nicht scrollen hier recht wir fragen mal okay wir fragen
Chat-GPT.
Wir nehmen jetzt mal...
Wir nehmen jetzt mal das hier, okay?
Das ist komplett...
Das ist komplett Magic.
Er hat heute Tunas getestet, ja.
Okay, was macht
das hier?
Erkläre mir das.
Mal gucken.
Das ist ein Stück C-Code aus dem Netzwerktreiber.
Ja, ich erkläre dir Schritt für Schritt
Ja, bin ich jetzt aber mal gespannt, ChatGPT
Würdest du für einen Anfänger
UgreenOS
Oder Trunas empfehlen?
Bin derzeit am überlegen, ob ich von
Ganz ehrlich, weder noch
Das UgreenOS kann man meiner Meinung nach
Knicken, genauso wie das MinisforumOS
Trunas habe ich
Lange nicht mal ausprobiert
Das letzte Mal hat es mir überhaupt nicht gefallen
Mal gucken, wird sich heute zeigen, ob das wieder so ist
Was du dir überlegen kannst
Also was ich jetzt seit Jahren hier schon verwende ist Unraid.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Wenn es dir hauptsächlich um Virtualisierung und Container geht, ist Proxmox auch nicht verkehrt.
Du musst dir halt überlegen, was du machen willst.
Wenn es dir wirklich nur rein um Netzwerkspeicher geht, dann kannst du dir das Ugreen OS mal angucken, ob das ausreicht.
Ich bin kein Fan von diesem Ugreen OS.
Was testen wir? Trunas Core oder Scale?
Das auf Linux-Basis.
Was ist das auf Linux-Basis?
Scale ist das auf Linux-Basis, oder?
Wollen die Truners nicht Closed Source machen?
Nee, oder? Wollen sie nicht?
Die haben den...
Die Build-Pipeline irgendwie ist jetzt...
Ist jetzt Closed, oder?
Wenn du viel mit Containern...
Wenn du viel mit Containern arbeitest,
ist die Frage...
Ist das Docker-Container? Willst du Docker verwenden?
Dann ist Proxmox jetzt nicht so geil zum Verwalten, weil Proxmox unterstützt keine Docker-Container.
Das ist auch wirklich so, ja.
Bevor jetzt einer kommt, der sagt, ah doch, aber mit der letzten Version.
Ne, es werden keine Docker-Container unterstützt.
Was unterstützt wird, ist einmalig Docker-Container zu konvertieren in das Format von Proxmox.
Aber das hätten wir sich meiner Meinung nach auch sparen können, ja.
Wenn du Docker verwenden willst, dann kannst du irgendein x-beliebiges Linux nehmen mit
Docker drauf.
Du kannst dir eine VM erstellen unter trunas, unter openmedia-vault, unter unraid, unter
proxmox, auf einem Debian nackig selbst, du kannst es auf dem Debian selbst machen.
Ja, was ich, wenn es hier nur um Docker-Container geht und man nicht viele alte Container und Anwendungen hat, die laufen und laufen, also quasi weiterlaufen müssen in der Zeit.
Ich finde Dogploy mega nice. Das habe ich mal ausprobiert hier auch im Stream.
Ich dachte auch am Anfang, so einen Kack braucht keiner.
Aber unterm Strich fand ich es echt nice.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, was uns ChatGPT hier Tolles erklärt.
Ja.
Kurz, diese Funktion konfiguriert die Hardware des Chips.
Okay, alles klar, toll.
Das ist ein Array für Register Schreibe...
Schreib... Was?
Register Schreibbefehlen. Aha, ja.
Jeder Eintrag bedeutet einen Wert.
Ja, mach Witz, ChatGPT.
Da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen.
Also, Chat-GPT, das ist typisch, ja.
Also, Chat-GPT hat logischerweise, das haben wir ja schon vermutet, auch keinen blassen Schimmer, was es macht.
Weil woher sollst du das auch wissen?
Guck hier, Magic Numbers.
Was im Endeffekt heißt, außer Realtek
Kann das keiner
Ändern
So, jetzt habe ich mich da ein bisschen drüber ausgelacht
Ich muss jetzt mal Chat lesen
Weil ich habe die letzten
20 Minuten durchgeschwätzt und kaum Chat geguckt
Was wird gevibecoded?
Wir haben uns versucht den Realtek-Treiber
Im Linux-Kernel von ChatGPT teilweise erklären zu lassen
Und ChatGPT hat natürlich
Versagt und da kann ChatGPT
Nichts für, es sind halt irgendwelche Magic-Byte-Werte
Die halt nur Realtek kennt
Die nicht benannt sind oder sonst was
Plastic, genau
Okay, dann erklär mal was wir ChatGPT fragen sollen
Und vor allem wie ChatGPT wissen soll was die einzelnen Magic Bytes von Realtek
Bedeuten was soll ich dann fragen wir können sie ausbringen sag mir was ich fragen soll dann frage ich das guck ob es besser ist
schon mal überlegt eine arm plattform aufzubauen strom ist die ukraine hat sogar
einen arm bass nass was wohl echt gut sein muss was stromverbrauch ist
als habe ich chat gibt hier schon zugemacht kann man es noch mal aufmachen
aber ich will keine armen plattform weil warum will ich keine armen plattform weiß
ich jetzt gerade auch nicht wahrscheinlich wegen xx nach virtualisierung oder sowas gute frage
warum ich keine armband will okay was bei ok dann fragen wir das machen wir was bedeuten hier die
einzelnen werte und register ich kann ja jetzt schon sagen okay was bedeutet also ein register
in diesem Realtek
Linux Kernel
oder in diesem Realtek
Netzwerktreiber
im Linux Kernel, okay?
Mehr kann ich jetzt auch nicht fragen, aber wie gesagt, was soll
da rauskommen? Woran soll ChatGPT wissen?
Ja, wisst ihr?
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel,
Ja, das kann es nicht wissen.
Woran soll es das denn wissen?
Das ist, ah,
Classic Realtek Muster, Leute.
Classic, Classic.
Ein typisches Realtek Muster ist das, Leute.
Aber es ist realistisch, Chat-GPT kann es ja auch nicht wissen.
Niemand außer Realtek-interne Entwickler wissen das.
Geht's, Kang?
Woher weißt du das alles?
gute frage und völlig berechtigt
reverse engineering über zeit aha okay die erzählt ist erzählt wieder ganz viel
aber hauptsache ist drin ehrliche grenze ich weiß nicht die exakte bedeutung
jedes einzelwert oder was das konkret im silizium macht ja außer wie tech weiß
dass keiner ich hoffe zumindest wie tag weiß dass ich war jetzt noch mal chat
lesen weil ich jetzt die letzten 20 minuten durchgängig geschwätzt habe also
lass mal kurz gucken
war die nudel mit lachs oder lieber nachts mit lachs mit nudeln okay das ist
das ist tatsächlich eine gute frage soll ich lieber nudeln mit lachs essen oder
lieber lachs mit nudeln ganz ehrlich das ist kulinarisch dieselbe sache
Hi IQ Chat GPT.
Ich habe heute Pizza gefuttert.
Chat. Ich habe sogar
selbstgemachte Pizza. Ich habe sogar ein Foto gemacht.
Aber wo habe ich mein Handy?
Das liegt nicht hier.
Das war echt exzellent.
From Mega Menü.
Okay. Also Chat.
Chat gucken.
Hast du eigentlich einen Stehschreibtisch oder
arbeit zu besitzen ja ich habe einen höhenverstellbaren schreibtisch den kann
man mit so einem hier habe ich so eine an so einem kabel so eine mini
fernbedienung den kann man hoch und runter fahren ja und ganz selten ganz
selten fahr ich den mal hoch ich habe keinen pizzaofen ganz selten fahr ich
den mal hoch und steht eine weile aber ich bin meistens zu faul führen
ich war aber schon knapp sieben kilometer rennen also was das angeht
bin ich heute schon bedient hast du das schon gesehen die wollen aktuell 200
euro pro server auf youtube werde ich jetzt geriggrollt oder was 250.000
revealing my new investment das ist ein jahr alt
Ja, das finde ich ja auch eine sinnvolle Geschichte.
Debian in der VM und darauf kann man dann DocPlay machen oder einfach nur Docker Compose oder sonst was.
So werde ich es auch machen.
Was für eine TrueNAS Version soll ich mir überhaupt verwenden?
Das wollen wir uns gleich angucken.
Keine Ahnung.
Docker Compose soll auch bald bei Unraid kommen.
Aha.
Scale.
ich finde es noch nicht kühnert ich hatte noch nie kühnert gerät keine ahnung
kursiv die bsd variante von tuners gern das habe ich das habe ich da habe ich einen test
gesehen auf youtube von dem von dem ubiquitin das das hat mir nicht gefallen ich weiß aber
aber nicht mal genau warum.
Da müsste ich mir das Review
nochmal angucken, warum es mir nicht gefallen hat.
Das war aber nicht so das.
Weiß ich jetzt aber gerade nicht.
Und so.
Chat.
Dann würde ich sagen, packen wir das Ding mal aus, oder?
Also das NAS packen wir aus.
Nicht das hier.
Das da.
Ach ne, wir gucken uns vorher nochmal schnell die Hardware an, die drin ist.
Also.
Es ist ein 4-Bay NAS.
Es hat einen Core i3 mit 6 Kernen.
Der 6 Kerne täuscht ein bisschen.
Das sind
4 Efficiency-Kompetenzen.
und zwei performance course im vergleich zum alten da war es noch eine fünfkerne cpu da war
es viel efficiency course und ein performance core also das sollte durchaus hier schon so 20
prozent oder so leistungen mehr bringen da kann ich nichts zu sagen hatte ich nicht habe ich mir
auch nicht angeguckt das ist das 2b nass oder 2 kann ich dir sagen ich das fand ich nicht so geil
weil moment moment da ich dir gleich dxp 2800 das ist das was hat mir daran nicht gefallen die cpu
ist relativ alt und schwachbrüstig gut du hast auch nur 2,5 gig netzwerkkarte
die kriegst du damit vielleicht saturated vielleicht doch nicht wenn ihr
zwei also wenn ihr zwei ein schübeln reichen hat das interne hat das interne
ss nv me ssds oder nicht okay du hast zwei interne nvme steckplätze also ganz
ehrlich für was kleines ja wenn du jetzt nicht irgendwie großartige performance oder 10 gig
brauchst ich das wahrscheinlich gar nicht so übel wenn ihr das reicht wenn ihr zwei platten reichen
wenn große sprünge kannst du performance technik mit der cpu erzähle ich machen
ich bin mir nicht mal sicher wenn du deine festplatte verschlüsselt hast eventuell noch
die Daten komprimierst drauf,
bin ich mir nicht mal sicher, ob die CPU
Encryption
plus Compression
die 2,5 Gig
Saturated kriegt. Wahrscheinlich
nicht.
Relativ wahrscheinlich nicht.
Oder knapp.
Aber die Leistung reicht ohne Probleme aus,
um, wenn du
effekt einfach nur platte reinhauen willst nur mit 1 drüber machen windows
share drauf ohne irgendwelche zusätzlichen sparen ziehen vielleicht
noch ein paar docker container die selbst nicht viel leistung brauchen also
du kannst jetzt daraufhin sich irgendwelche sachen oder so laufen
lassen ja wenn du da irgendwie einen
assistent drauf laufen lassen willst oder so das geht denke ich ohne
Probleme.
Aber da kannst du keine großen Sprünge erwarten
von der CPU. Da ist tatsächlich
das Minisforum
Ding ist da richtig nice
von der Performance her.
Weil guck mal, du hast hier
einen 8-Kern-Risen.
Ein ziemlich
ordentlicher.
Der hat Wumms.
8-Kern-Risen.
8 Kerne, 16 Threads.
Also Hardware-mäßig ist das Minisforum echt nicht übel.
So, und bei dem U-Creen hast du halt jetzt einen Intel Core i3 drin, sechs Kerne, also vier Efficiency Cores, zwei Performance Cores.
Du hast eine Aquantia 10 Gigabit Netzwerkkarte, einmal eine 2,5 Gigabit Netzwerkkarte.
Es kommt mit 8 Gigabyte RAM.
Du kannst zwei, das stimmt übrigens gar nicht genau, das Ding hat drei NVMe-Anschlüsse, aber du kommst an zwei nur dran.
Bei dem anderen muss das Gehäuse komplett aufmachen und vier Festplatten einschübeln.
Ansonsten, glaube ich, war es das mit spannenden Sachen.
Was auch immer die mit KI haben, hier fragt nicht.
Das ist so die typische Sache, jeder braucht irgendwo so einen KI-Sticker und hat mit dem ganzen Ding, das Ding hat mit KI absolut gar nichts zu tun.
Professionelle Datensicherheit.
Ah ja, das hängt ein bisschen davon ab, was man damit macht, würde ich sagen.
Das hier ist alles bla bla bla bla.
Bla bla bla bla.
Leise Kühlung.
Das war tatsächlich, also das alte, das 4800 Plus, war tatsächlich relativ leise.
Das stimmt.
Da, wo ich es ausprobiert habe.
Warum man das Ding als Heimkinozentrale verwenden soll,
weiß ich jetzt auch nicht.
Ganz ehrlich,
das fällt wahrscheinlich als Heimkinozentrale
schon weg.
Wegen HDCP oder so. Ach, keine Ahnung.
Das schreiben die einfach nur hin.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es eine gute Heimkinozentrale
ist.
Vielleicht als Film-Backend,
wo die Filme drauf liegen oder transcoded
werden vielleicht.
Aber bestimmt nicht im Wohnzimmer
an fernseher angeschlossen das kann man nicht vorstellen dass es dafür dass dafür gut ist
mal eine sd karten slot
ja dass das dass dieses ukraine os das fliegt bei mir immer gleich in sind würde ich in sind
runter hauen so was hat man hier hdmi usb 2 x usb 2 2,5 10 gig nochmal usb c mit
10 gig nochmal usb 3 2 10 gig und sd karten wieder genau so sieht's aus
da würde ich sagen chat ich hole mal kurz das paket dann packe ich das ausschließt
an ich schließe die kvm an dass wir gucken können
dann schauen wir mal ich schließe erstmals erst mal kvm an können wir
dass wir direkt beim guten sehen was sache ist aber ich muss immer kurz holen
was aus meinem recipe aber wobei sage ich gleich was zu resten keller
So, also ich habe hier mein KVM-Ding am Start.
Das werde ich gerade mal kurz anschließen.
Ja, da kann ich was zu meinem Raspberry Pi im Keller erzählen.
Also, Raspberry Pi im Keller ist mir verreckt.
Oh, Mist.
Ups, ups, ups.
Äh.
Shred.
Ich habe gerade die Verlängerung für mein Headset runtergeschmissen.
Ich hoffe, ihr seid jetzt nicht, euch ist nicht irgendwie das Ohr geplatzt oder so.
Der hat hier...
Also, Raspberry Pi im Keller ist verreckt.
Der hat MQTT gemacht für...
Warte mal, was hat der gemacht?
Der hat für die Tür-Gegensprechanlage Notifications verschickt.
Der hat die Heizung ausgelesen.
Und was hat er noch gemacht?
Er hat irgendwas per MQTT geschickt.
Wartet mal, ich hab's doch auf Twitter geschrieben.
Klingel, Klingel.
Tür-Gegensprechanlage, das hab ich ja schon erzählt.
Der hat drei größere Sachen gemacht.
Wie gesagt, Tür-Gegensprechanlage, Heizung.
bin ich jetzt dumm, Alter? Ich weiß nicht mehr, was die Kiste gemacht hat.
Aber zum Glück
habe ich das Ganze
auf
Twitter geschrieben.
Hier, V-Control für die Heizung.
Notifications für die Klingel.
MQTT für die
Wetterstation, genau.
Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz hier meine Verlängerung
nochmal richten.
Genau.
MQTT für die Wetterstation hat er noch
gemacht.
Ich habe den Raspberry Pi noch nicht
geborgen.
Oh shit, das Ding ist im Arsch. Das sackt.
Das ist aber mal richtig...
Das ist irgendwie kaputt.
Ich hoffe, jetzt geht's wieder.
Also,
ich hab den Raspberry Pi noch nicht aus dem Keller geborgen.
Ich geh ungern in den Keller.
Da ist die Chance auf eklige Viecher immer hoch.
Hardware im Arsch oder nur die SSD?
Ich tippe auf die Hardware und nicht die SSD.
Ich geh davon aus, wenn ich mich im Keller traue,
um den Raspberry Pi zu bergen
und die SSD wird in den Reader gesteckt,
dann geht die, dann geht die.
Geh ich mal von aus.
Hoffe ich und geh ich aber trotzdem auch mal von aus.
So, also jetzt schließen wir mal kurz die KVM-Geschichte hier an.
KVM-Stells, zack.
Zack, Strom an.
Netzwerkstecker rein.
So, und jetzt gehen wir mal auf die IP von der KVM.
kann nämlich gleich zu gucken wie das ukraine ding bootet 144 an die graf ist
noch nicht gestartet vielleicht wurde auch vor was gefressen
tja wer weiß was für riesige gefressene dinge dass ich da im keller so tummeln
Gibt es bekannte Insekten, die Raspberry Pis fressen?
MonkaW?
Äh.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat die KVM eine neue IP.
119.
Okay.
Advanced.
Proceed.
Massive geheimes Passwort.
Kommt keiner drauf.
So, da sind wir.
Kein Signal detected. Ja klar, ich hab's ja auch nicht
angeschlossen. Dann geh ich jetzt mal kurz
in den Flur, hol das Paket mit dem Nass
und wir schließen es an.
Und dann
schauen wir mal.
Ähm...
Moment, Leute.
Wo hab ich denn ein Netzwerkkabel?
Ich brauch noch ein Netzwerkkabel.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
So, ich packe das Ding mal kurz aus.
Das ist wieder...
Also eins muss man den China-Chinesen ja lassen.
Gut verpackt ist der Krempel, echt.
Da ist so ein Plastikding drumherum.
Da drin ist jetzt nochmal ein Karton drin.
Machst du gerade mal ab.
Nochmal ein Karton drin.
Und in dem Karton ist garantiert nochmal ein Karton.
Und in dem Karton nochmal ein Karton.
Also so, Plastiktüte ab.
Das Warranty-Seal wird removed.
Oh, zack, zack, Karton auf.
Karton auf.
Im Karton ist nochmal ein Karton.
Das dachte ich mir fast.
Oh, geh raus, Nass.
So, jetzt mache ich den nächsten Karton auf.
Und in dem Karton ist wahrscheinlich nochmal ein Karton.
In dem Karton ist...
Ne, da ist das Nass jetzt direkt drin.
Okay.
Nass stellst...
Raus mit dir.
Exzellent.
Oh, jetzt wäre es mir fast runtergefallen.
Das wäre jetzt schlecht gewesen.
600 Euro Nass erstmal.
So, und hier ist...
Netzteil und sonstige Geschichten.
Alles klar.
Nasses ausgepackt.
Dann machen wir jetzt noch die
Plastiktüte drumherum ab,
die ums Nass drumherum ist.
Da ist irgendein Staubfilter drin.
Den brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
Und öffnen, please.
Naske.
Boah.
Leute.
da stinkt das ding alter nach china chinesen hardware stinkt das so richtig so richtig diesen
diesen komischen ekligen technikgeruch hat so nass steht vor mir wir schließen es mal an also hdmi
guck mal wo ist denn der anschluss hdmi anschluss dann usb anschluss an den usbc hat das ding usb
USB-C-Stecker? Haben wir doch gerade irgendwo gesehen, ne?
USB-C-Anschluss, jawoll.
Das war's. Jetzt brauche ich noch ein Netzwerkkabel.
Moment, Moment, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Alles angeschlossen.
Was für Platten nutzt du im Nass?
Also jetzt gerade ist das Ding noch komplett leer.
Ich werde später dann, aber wie gesagt, ich benutze das Minisform Nass.
höchstwahrscheinlich und nicht dieses Ugreen, was wir
heute ausprobieren. Aktuell
habe ich für die Bestückung eine
24TB Platte.
Und wenn das Ding sich bewährt nach dem Einrichten,
dann schucke ich mir noch eine zweite für 499
Euro dabei.
Und mache dann ein Raid 1.
24TB reichen mir.
Für Backups
brauche ich nicht mehr.
Ich könnte mir noch zwei schucken und ein Raid 5
machen. Wobei ihr wisst, dass ich
überhaupt kein Fan von Raid 5 mehr bin.
Vor allem nicht bei so großen Platten.
Mit drei so großen Platten wäre es gerade so, aber wirklich gerade so noch vertretbar.
Patrick, danke schön für den Sub.
So, Handbuch schmeiße ich erstmal weg.
Wer braucht ein Handbuch?
Gibt es irgendjemand von euch, der freiwillig Handbücher liest?
Handbuch ist komplett outdated, overrated, jebaited, oder?
Niemand liest Handbücher.
Manchmal wäre es gar nicht so blöd, ehrlich gesagt.
aber trotzdem das sagt einfach nur handbücher lesen so haben wir das stromkabel ein stink
normaler kaltgeräte stecker das muss jetzt in so eine netzwerk netzteil brick rein
jawohl und dann haben wir hier haben wir noch wärmepads für die ssds
billig china chinesen schraubendreher und ein netzwerkkabel okay das brauchen wir
jetzt beides nicht alles in die ecke pfeffern gut dann schließen wir das gleiche mal an an
mein strom mess also nicht droben leistungs messgerät guck mal wie viel watt das ding im
eitel zieht nachdem was eingerichtet haben der gereihen so leute es kann gebootet werden
das 4300 ist ein armlast oder docker auf nass soll festplatten sleep verhindern ist das so
wenn du da kein drauf hast kann ich mir nicht vorstellen warum das so sein sollte wenn du halt
permanent auf die disks jahre klarer kannst du nicht liegen ich mache mal an leute moment vorher
muss ich mal kurz google wie man da ins bios kommt you cream das enter how to you krimas enter bios
i try to enter the bios bei hitting control f 12 control f2 das connect keyboard and monitor
wie jetzt hier. Ctrl-F
12 or delete.
Das ist bestimmt
Cheap-Aid, ja. Ich will jetzt nicht
UGOS booten.
Will ich gar nicht. Ich will gar kein
China-Chinesen-Zeug bei mir im Netzwerk booten.
Wir machen es jetzt einfach so. Ich schalte jetzt ein
und spamme sofort
Ctrl-F. Oh.
Ich kann nicht Ctrl-F 12 spammen,
weil das irgendwas macht.
dann spamme ich
entfernen.
Also das Ding leuchtet schon mal und blinkt.
Das klingt doch schon mal ganz gut.
Macht das jetzt was?
Ukraine!
Ich drücke jetzt einfach mal Enf.
Aha.
Okay. Haha. Ich will kein
China-Chinesen-Zeug booten. Geh weg!
Na gut, können wir jetzt sagen, Ctrl Alt Del zum Neustarten?
Ullbox.
Ctrl F, ach fuck, Alter.
Moment, wir müssen
gerade mal irgendwie gucken, dass ich
Control und F12 drücken kann.
Das mag der ja nicht so ganz.
Wahrscheinlich, weil man KDE da irgendwas
macht.
So, wir bleiben erstmal kurz im Bootmanager.
Okay.
Control, F12.
Das hidet irgendwelche Fenster.
Ähm.
Shortcuts oder so?
Wie kann man das...
F12?
Lasst mal...
Control-F12. Ja, geh weg.
Apply. Braucht ihr keiner.
Okay, jetzt geht's.
Toolbox.
Control-Alt-Entfernen.
Kann man einen eigenen Shortcut hinzufügen?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich spamme jetzt erstmal.
Aha, guck mal da.
Bam.
Enter Setup.
Da sind wir.
So und ich glaube man kann, es gibt ein advancedes BIOS bei den Ukraines wo man rein kann.
Ich glaube mit F2.
Oder Ukraine NAS Enter Advanced BIOS.
сятсят
сят
Nervt.
F2.
Okay, das schauen wir nicht.
Äh, Rename?
What?
Ach so.
Oh, das ist ja mies.
Das ist mein Logitech-Treiber,
der da jetzt Probleme macht mit F2.
Oh Mann.
Warum sind das doch immer so kryptische
Shortcuts, Alter?
Da muss ich erst mal
meinen Marker... Ich hab doch einen Marker auf F2.
Und
das mag dann irgendwie nicht.
So, kann man das disable?
Kann man das
irgendwie ausschalten oder so?
selbe jetzt komplett weg
f2 controller 2
und schuld auf zwei ist es nicht f2 ist es auch nicht
ach so moment
Wartet mal.
Es ist jetzt komplett ausgeschaltet.
Okay, das ist natürlich auch dumm.
Use Default.
Okay.
Aber es geht trotzdem nicht.
Das ist also F2 macht jetzt
Äh, äh, was jetzt?
War das jetzt
Okay
4800 plus
Bios Optimization
Hab ich, da gibt es den Bios
Gab es den Bios Thread für
Achso
Just boot into Bios
And hit CTRL F1
Control F1 ist es.
Okay.
Use Default.
Control F1.
Ah.
Das ist schon besser, oder?
Ja.
Jetzt haben wir ordentliche
BIOS Settings.
dauert es jetzt drei Stunden, sich da durchzukämpfen.
Das ist mal richtig advanced, oder?
So, jetzt können wir das
wieder umkonfigurieren.
Ich hoffe, das bleibt jetzt auch so.
Wenn ich jetzt sage,
save changes and reset,
So, jetzt will ich Netzwerkboot machen.
Wie sage ich dem, dass ich Netzwerkboot machen will?
Kann man das, konnte man das im Bootmenü irgendwie auswählen?
Oder muss man das im BIOS erst noch einschalten, dass Netzwerkboot geht?
Ähm.
Ich sehe hier nicht Netzwerkboot.
Was für eine Seite benutzt du da, um auf das NAS zuzugreifen?
Das ist meine KVM.
dass das stöpseln hdmi und usb dran und das ist quasi ein eigenes gerät wurde
dann im browser dich drauf verbindet und das tippt es dann per usb ein
das ist hier gl kvm
so und moment moment das ist das falsch das habe ich nicht haben die vielleicht
auch mal irgendwas.
Äh, GL.
Die wissen nicht genau.
Äh, hier.
KVM.
Das ist die nicht.
Das ist nicht die, die ich hab.
Ich hab das Ding hier.
Das hier
Ja, finde ich eigentlich auch ganz gut
Das kostet zwar ein bisschen was
Aber im Vergleich zu professionellen KVM Lösungen
Da kannst du ja noch teilweise eine 0 hinten dran hängen
So ist es eigentlich echt ganz gut
Das Schöne ist, dass sogar Speicher integriert ist
Du kannst das Ding auch als USB Stick
Zweck entfremden
So, wie bringe ich dem jetzt bei
dass der Preis ist
vollkommen in Ordnung.
Link please.
Das Ding heißt,
das müsst ihr selbst suchen.
Das Ding heißt
Comet Pro.
Ja.
Achso, ich kann ja nicht mehr rauscopypasten
aus der VM hier.
Ja, das müsst ihr halt
selbst abtippen jetzt. Comet Pro
GL, Inert,
Comet Pro, KVM.
Es gibt auch noch andere Sachen.
Es gibt noch JetKey, KVM,
Pi, KVM, Nano,
KVM und so. Gibt ja ein paar
in der Richtung.
Ich benutze es aber
übrigens nicht über Wi-Fi.
So, also
wie machen wir jetzt
Network Stack Configuration?
LAN Boot Enabled
IPv4
PXE Support
HTTP Support
Brauchen wir nicht, PXE Support
PXE Boot Wait Time
Äh, Leute
Mein BIOS ist einfach gestorben
Was ist das?
Mein BIOS ist einfach gestorben gerade
Was ist das für ein Kack?
den watch den watch stock ausmachen
ok advanced watch dogs disable müssen wir gehen watch stock settings watch
control in disable networkstech configuration enable pxe boot wait time
chat wie wie wie kann ich jetzt hier ab plus minus ok zwei sekunden save und exit
Okay, dann machen wir mal PXE-Boot.
Dü, dü, dü.
Hallo?
Bootstelz?
HVM?
Oder Minisforum?
Was auch immer.
Ja.
Horse Champ
Okay
Er hat zumindest
Ich kann gar nichts mehr
Ich darf gar nichts mehr tippen
Was ist das jetzt? Ah jetzt geht es wieder
Also wir wollen booten über
Ah guck mal da ist auch eine Aquantia
AQC
NIC Linux
Aquantia
Atlantic?
Was?
Okay, wir wollen von der
booten. Jetzt ist das Ding, habe ich jetzt überhaupt
eine richtige Netzwerkkarte?
Angeblich habe ich 10 Gig
Verbindung. Ich spekuliere jetzt einfach
mal drauf, dass hier ist die richtige Netzwerkkarte, die ich auch
angeschlossen habe.
Starte
das verdammte Spiel.
Okay, es scheint
scheint zu booten.
C-States noch aktivieren. Das machen wir dann
alles, wenn wir was installiert haben.
Mein aktuell verbrauchtes Ding
34 Watt. Ja, das
ist zu viel für nix.
Aber warten wir mal ab.
Warten wir mal ab, bis wir ein
Betriebssystem drauf installiert haben.
Okay, also. Dann
würde ich sagen,
wie war das?
Ich soll das interne
Ich soll das interne OS auf erstmal sichern, oder?
Hat irgendjemand gesagt.
Dann machen wir das doch mal.
Starten wir mal Clonezilla.
Clonezilla.
Ich stecke da eine SD-Karte rein.
Wir machen das mit SD-Karte.
Wenn das Ding noch einen SD-Karten-Slot hat...
Link ist ab.
Zwei HDDs tut das Verbrauch 30 Watt, wenn die HDDs drehen.
Das erscheint mir aber auch ein bisschen viel. Eine Festplatte, die aktuell abgespinnt ist, braucht 8 Watt oder so. Das heißt, dann braucht dein anderes System auch nochmal 16, brauchen deine Festplatten 14. Ja, aber für die 2800 ist das tatsächlich, finde ich, ein bisschen viel.
Aber um wie viel braucht ein Nas mit Spin-Down-Platten?
30 Watt mit zwei Platten angeht ja noch irgendwie.
Aber Spin-Down sollte es schon unter 10 Watt sein.
Guck mal, Chainlaw ist am Start.
Start Clonezilla or enter Login-Shell.
Ich will Clonezilla starten.
Okay, wenn die Fritzbox noch dran hängt, dann verstehe ich das.
Start Clonezilla.
Achso, ich muss erstmal eine SD-Karte reinstöpseln.
Moment, SD-Karte.
Muss ich erstmal über die ganzen Kartons hier drüber kommen.
Okay.
da machen wir mal eine sd karte rein
sd karte ist drin dort clowns oder hätte ich die vorher vorher machen müssen also wie von
stars denn lang oder wobei ist auch gar nicht so lange her wo ich das letzte mal
verwendet habe work with discs partitions using images ok
use a local device yes continue you can install device into the machine
habe ich hier flash drive ja stb oder
ssdb messstorch class things der stb ist das hast du die etc ram probleme die fix
ich wenn ich die mikro risse im mainboard auch gefix ab was mich control c ok also sdb
was now we need the tomorrow the device so we can read or save the image you should not mount
the partition you want to backup es ja okay das ist das ist okay hier ist stb 1
ok
witch directory ist vor der klausel repository
was will es von mir da habe ich schon backup drauf vom januar
dann
ok so johann zu synchron aus der zeit synchronisierte time mach meinetwegen
enter so beginner safe disk perfekt die ssd will ich speichern ok
ähm
for multicore cpu
ok
skip check repairing
ok fsck
yes check the saved image
ok
do not encrypt the image
copy log files
ok choose
continue so jetzt sollte er die Sachen backuppen
continue yes
Let's do it
Also die Benutzerführung von Clonezilla
Könnte man auch schon schöner machen, oder?
Okay, ist backupped
No space left on device incoming
Ne, warum?
Die Dase nicht viel benutzt
Die ssd ist zwar 128 gig groß und meine sd ist nur 60 gig groß aber benutzt ist davon ja nur ein paar gig
Der will mich doch nicht ernsthaft erzählen, dass er mit 7 Gigabyte die Sekunde auf die
SD-Karte schreibt.
Das ist doch Hardcore G-Bait wieder.
You got G-Baited.
G-G-G-G-G-Baited.
Den Chebaded Song hatten wir schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Wartet mal kurz.
Wo habe ich den denn überhaupt?
Wo ist der?
Wo ist der Chebaded Song?
Hier.
So.
Jetzt haben wir die Zeit überbrückt, bis
Clonezilla den Kram fertig...
Oh, guck mal! Wir haben eine
Maus-
Function hier im Terminal.
Ganz advances Zeug.
Danach noch das Backup
testen. Ich teste keine Backups.
YOLO.
Backups testen ist overrated, outdated,
jebaited.
Wenn einfach alles fehlerfrei
läuft,
dann muss man auch nichts testen.
Ist doch ganz klar.
Sag mal, was
backt der da eigentlich
drei Stunden?
Ne, der ist schon beim Verifizieren vom Backup
gerade, richtig?
oder glaub schon oder auch nicht
starting to check image doch doch doch der check gerade der md5 summen grad die
die backups
Enter
Äh, okay
Reboot
Trying to unmount, done, unmount
Okay, dann mach ich die SD-Karte jetzt raus, leg die hier nebenhin
Jetzt starten wir nochmal über PXE
Und dann gucken wir, ob wir Trunas starten können
Wisst ihr zufällig
ob Trunas
in Netboot XYZ
drin ist.
Wenn nicht, gucken wir einfach mal.
Hallo.
Okay, zack.
Schauen wir mal,
ob da Trunas drin ist.
Sonst müssen wir unsere TrueNAS ISO runterladen und auf die KVM, auf das KVM-Device uploaden.
Ist das mit dem PXE-Boot nicht mega nice?
Ich finde das enorm pog.
Und außerdem ist das Hintergrundbild richtig pog, auch wenn es KI-generiertes Hintergrundbild ist.
Aber schönster PXE-Boot-Screen, Alter.
So, ähm, Netboot.
So, ist da Trunas dabei?
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt jetzt.
Okay, wenn schon ist es wahrscheinlich bei Linux Network Installs.
Okay, da ist schon mal kein TrueNAS dabei.
Äh, Live-CDs?
Aber TrueNAS ist ja kein Live-CD.
Kein TrueNAS.
Okay, netbootxyz, TrueNAS gibt's net.
Okay, kein, dann müssen wir TrueNAS so runterladen.
Äh.
Ich bin schon mal überfordert mit der Webseite.
Solutions?
TrueNAS Community Edition, das brauchen wir, oder?
truenas.com
Download.
Truenas Community Edition.
Aha.
Okay.
Ne, mittlerweile
ist es nicht mehr BSD. Früher war das
BSD. Zur Zeit, also
es war zu Freenas Zeiten war das BSD, danach war es immer noch BSD, aber die bauen schon seit einer ganzen Weile an der Linux basierten Sache rum.
Ursprünglich hatten sie für Containermanagement irgendein komisches Single-Node-Kubernetes-Setup, das fand ich ganz weird.
Okay, Downloads, Community Edition.
Und jetzt? Subscribe to the Newsletter. Was? Alter, wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Hackw
at lulhd
xd.com
Nee, das ist keine
Valid E-Mail. Wirklich nicht.
Ach, no.
Ach, das ist klickbar.
Das ist klickbar.
Das sieht nicht klickbar aus.
Das ist ein
sogenanntes Dark Pattern.
25,10.
Warum genau sollte ich 504 verwenden, wenn ich auch 25,10 verwenden kann?
Macht doch keinen Sinn, oder?
Ne, wenn das LTS wäre, würde das bestimmt dahinter stehen.
Das glaube ich nicht, Chat.
Which version is right for me?
Wir können auch 26 Nightly verwenden.
Wenn schon, denn schon.
Okay, wir sollen 2510 verwenden.
Außer Mission Critical.
Gehen wir schon mal hier und uploaden das gleich.
Aber nur 2 Gbps, das heißt der Download ist halbwegs geschwind.
Okay, also Virtual Media.
Wir löschen mal das alte Cache-US da drauf.
Upload, Downloads, Tuners.
Ich finde es immer geil, wenn man schneller aus dem Internet runter lädt, als lokal irgendwas zu kopieren.
Chat sagt PopOS schreibt auch ihr OS sei LTS
Aber es ist die Beta Version
Und was ist der Hintergrund
Weshalb machen die sowas
Ich mein es macht ja überhaupt keinen Sinn
Eigentlich eine Beta Version als LTS zu verkaufen
Ich mein LTS heißt ja eigentlich nur
Long Term Support
Das heißt ja nicht wie stabil das ganze ist
ich kann auch eine beta version long term supporten
ist popo es nicht immer beta ich habe keine ich glaube ich bin mir nicht
sicher ich glaube wir haben popo es vor jahren oder so mal in der vm installiert
und da hat es mir nicht gefallen vielleicht ist das mittlerweile viel
besser
arch by the way beste ok also dann mount to remote image mounting und zwar trunas
scale soll gemountet werden zack toolbox control alt delete
Und spammen wir mal F12.
F12, F12, F12, F12, F12.
Irgendwie ist die KVM buggy.
Guck mal, ich muss immer reloaden die Seite, dass es wieder funktioniert.
Sehr, sehr weirdchampig.
So, hier.
Jetzt starten wir
von dem USB-Speicher.
Da mach doch mal das Update.
Ne.
Mach ich nicht.
Wir könnten updaten.
Wir könnten die KVM updaten von
161 auf 187.
Nicht geupdatet.
Truna Scale Installation.
wollen wir mal jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das taugt
so install upgrade shut down her gut install auf die ssd jawohl okay das
er ist es all partitions ich muss da noch ich muss da noch platten und
so dran stöpsel aber erst mal machen wir die installation
Yes
Ähm
Tuners Admin, was muss ich jetzt machen
Passwort, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Top Secret
Äh
Den Installer finde ich echt eklig
gebe ich dir recht, Mayonnaise.
Der Installer wirkt wirklich wie aus dem
letzten Jahrtausend.
Dabei finde ich den
aktuellen Debian-Installer, der sieht
auch aus wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend,
ist aber schön zweckmäßig.
Was ich echt
gut finde, ist der Open Media Vault
Installer. Der ist
schön simpel und geht schnell.
Warum man jetzt nicht hier einfach, wenn man da eh schon so ein Endcurses-Ding hat, nicht einfach hier jetzt einen Progress Bar gemacht hat und hier so, das ist keine Ahnung.
Das ist schon ekliger Installer.
Nutzt du für Linux-Server immer noch Ubuntu?
Ne, Debian.
Ubuntu verwende ich schon seit Jahren nicht mehr.
Ubuntu hat mich verloren
als sie angefangen haben
immer mehr normale Packages
die man installiert über apt auf snap
umzustellen und ich finde auch
Netplan, also Netzwerk Confirm mit YAML
finde ich irgendwie, äh
So, Trunas Installation
Installation
succeeded
Na gut, so schlimm war der Installer jetzt ja nur wirklich nicht
Reboot
Warum kann ich keine Netzwerk-Config oder so festlegen?
Im Installer wäre doch mal ganz praktisch gewesen.
Oh.
KVM spackt rum.
U-Green.
Truner Scale.
Sleeping 4
Okay
Es bootet
Wait on Discs?
Ja, auf welche Discs?
Ich habe ja noch gar keine drinne.
So wirklich gut was erkennen kann man da nicht.
Ich mache mal groß.
Es scheint so, dass die von ZFS booten, ne?
Hätte ich jetzt vermutet.
Das Booten dauert schon mal irgendwie 3 Stunden.
Was machen die da eigentlich so lange beim Booten?
Sleepge.
Bettge macht der.
DHCP braucht doch keine Minute
DHCP geht bam bam bam
Bam
Also naja
Mit dem aktuellen
HP Mini PC den ich hab
oder Macro-Server, den ich habe, habe ich vier Nasses.
Richtig sinnlos.
Aber in Benutzung habe ich aktuell nur
eins.
Okay, Config Network
Interfaces, Config
Network Settings,
Config Static Routes.
Das kann ich doch bestimmt auch alles über das Webinterface
machen, oder?
1 und 2, 1 und 2, 2.1, 1,
8.
Okay, was ist es? Admin? 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6. Oder
True NAS Admin?
stand doch da irgendwie was tun das admin ja okay nice check for updates erstmal updates
schadet system ist abtodate gut so da war das ein bisschen größer alles dass ihr auch ordentlich was
sieht gut jetzt konfigurieren wir mal die also das ist die andere netzwerkkarte sowie konfiguriert
man jetzt seine netzwerkkarte hier zeigt man ihr network das ist es edit static
ob die frei ist nicht dass ich mir jetzt vertue
slash 24
und wo muss ich gateway und so einstellen
jetzt okay primäre dns server sekundäre dns kann es gibt es nicht gibt es nicht
Gateway Register
Must be tested. Okay, test changes.
Test changes.
und jetzt muss ich hier auf 54 oder was schulers admin 1 2 3 4 5 6 ok goto netzwerk setup safe
changes das haben die legit ganz nice gemacht dass du dich nicht ausspülen kannst das finde
ich eigentlich ganz gut das gibt das das finde ich finde ich übel also da kann ich schon mal
sagen da hat sich einer gedanken drüber gemacht okay jetzt haben statische ip auf dem ding das
hier stimmt alles zack von open media world media world musste auch ein klein ja aber diese sache
mit du musst erst auf die neue ip gehen ansonsten rollt er zurück auf die alte das hat media world
glaube ich nicht aber finde ich finde ich ganz gut ok check for updates hatten wir schon up to date
So, was kann man jetzt hier so machen? Ich habe es lange nicht verwendet.
Dashboard juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
So, was wir jetzt machen ist, als allererstes mal, kann man sich da per SSH drauf verbinden.
Ich will nämlich ein IPerf machen.
Keine Ahnung, admin, add, 192.165.4?
Ne, okay, SSH ist schon mal nicht an.
Dann kommt das erste, wie schaltet man SSH an?
Shell, excellent.
Ist es ein Debian?
abt exzellent update package management tools a disabled und schulers appliances
tempel gehabt und wie kann ich jetzt da was nach installieren ich würde ich
würde gerne schulers in ebel ab ich will ich will mal ich will ein paar
installieren
Okay, das ist anscheinend schon mal nicht so gedacht
Das ist schon mal nicht so gedacht
You there have an supported developer mode that you can activate
install devtools
ok
bam
ich glaube
das sollte man eigentlich gar nicht machen
Ich will jetzt einfach mal schnell mit IPerf testen, wie die Netzwerk-Performance von dem Ding ist.
Jetzt bestimmt unter Apps.
Gucken wir gleich mal.
Gucken wir, gucken wir gleich mal.
Ich will erstmal ohne irgendwelche Container oder sonst was einfach mal einen IPerf machen, so schnell wie es geht.
Also, einen IPerf, der so schnell wie es geht läuft.
Okay, apt install iperf3.
Apt, apt.
Ach, ist iperf schon drauf?
ipad ist schon drauf 0 ok hätten wir das uns mit dem entwickler modus aktivieren können
aussparen können desktop ipad 54 das ist das ist schön viel besser als die schrott netzwerk karte
auf dem Minisform
nass. Das ist mal ordentlich.
Ja, genau so muss das sein.
So muss das sein, Leute.
Das ist ordentliche 10-Gig-Performance.
So muss die sein.
Ja, 9,4 bis
9,5 in jede Richtung.
So, genau so ist richtig.
Jetzt machen wir nochmal hier
die Directional
Ja, genau so.
So muss 10 Gig Performance sein.
Nicht dieser Schrott von der Realtek-Karte.
Excellent.
Unexpected Start ist okay.
Ah ja, jetzt funktioniert es.
Uptinstall Tmux.
Ist schon installiert.
Okay, da sind ja sogar Pa...
Äh, was?
Okay.
Was steckt da für eine Karte drinne?
Eine Aquantia...
Warte mal, kann ich dir sagen?
Schauen wir mal.
LSPCI.
Äh, LSPCI.
Das ist eine Aquantia AQC113.
Irgendwie dachte ich bis heute, die heißen Aquantik, aber nein, die heißen Aquantia.
Excellent.
So, dann schauen wir mal, was gibt es denn hier?
Apps, no application installed, check.
Kollaborer
Store J
Available Apps
Okay, machen wir mal
Suchen wir mal nach Git
Gibt es nicht
Gibt es 4G oder wie das andere heißt
Ne, äh, Git
Gibt nix
Ähm
Okay, was gibt es denn da so
Bogeo gibt es nicht
Refresh Katalog
Machen wir nochmal
Jetzt gibt es das
Hä
Okay
Keine Ahnung
Jetzt geht es aber
Setup Pool
Achso, ja
Und fahren
Create Pool
Das geht jetzt nicht, weil ich keine
Ja, blub
Layout
Disk Size
Jaja, ich habe ja keine Disks
Ich habe ja keine Disk drin.
So, dann muss ich jetzt erstmal eine Disk reinmachen in das NAS,
dass das funktioniert.
Datasets.
Moment, das läuft standardmäßig nicht auf ZFS?
Das Root-File-System?
Oder wie ist das?
System, Shell.
Gucken wir nochmal kurz.
Zpool-Status.
Doch.
Läuft es auch.
Kann man nur nicht über das Web-Interface.
ich kann ja kein youtube videos machen wir nach gerade nicht frei im kopf für aber ich
werde nie komplett aufhören also es wird auf jeden fall wieder videos geben ich kann ja
aber nicht sagen wann wie macht man jetzt hier nochmal ssh access am ssh system warum
man den anfassen sollte im webinterface zum beispiel diskreplacement oder so wenn man
сятtings
System?
Ah, Services.
SSH.
Automatic.
Passwort Logging Groups.
Was für Dinger?
Achso.
allow password authentication okay probleme ssh bm schulers admin was ist das richtige überhaupt
mit dem ukraine ersetzen glaube ich nicht trans settings
Ach hier, Trunas Admin.
Kann man da machen.
Okay, save.
Okay.
Das haben die eigentlich ganz schick gemacht.
Muss ich sagen.
Finde ich gar nicht übel, die Oberfläche.
Ja.
Finde ich geht eigentlich ganz gut klar.
Der ist sogar startmäßig.
sicher ja das ist das ist echt in ordnung so sammler schalten wir auch auf
jeden fall schon mal an
das war ein settings
ok keine ahnung lassen wir lassen wir die fault
N-V-M-E-O-F.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist. Was ist das?
Over Fabrics.
Soll was bedeuten?
Fiber Channel.
N-V-M-E über Fiber Channel.
YouTube Videos sind für mich anstrengender als streamen.
Ich kann dir auch nicht so genau erklären.
Also, wer hat hier gefragt? Der Dude.
Ich kann dir das auch nicht erklären.
YouTube Videos finde ich anstrengender.
Also ich kann ohne Probleme vier, fünf Stunden streamen, sechs Stunden streamen.
Das ist dann zwar auch anstrengend, aber juckt mich nicht weiter.
YouTube-Videos finde ich zu anstrengend.
Ich kann dir nicht sagen, warum. Keine Ahnung.
Ich war es nicht.
Gut, was haben wir hier sonst noch?
Äh.
Hier kann man auch sagen, Bootpool.
Settings. Okay.
So, was
haben wir hier sonst noch? Apps.
Können wir gleich aus mit Virtual Machines.
Containers.
Angeblich habe ich gelesen,
Trunas kann auch
Docker Compose verwenden.
Pool.
Credentials.
Data Protection.
Da kann man irgendwelche Offsite Backups machen, Netzwerkshares, Datasets.
Okay, jetzt würde ich sagen, haben wir ungefähr nur so einen Überblick.
Was ist das?
Send Feedback, Status of True Command.
Was?
Connect to True Command Cloud.
Status of Trunas Connect.
Nein, will ich auch nicht.
WTF? Running Jobs?
Alerts?
Oh, also ganz im Ernst,
das Interface finde ich eigentlich recht
zweckmäßig und gut gemacht, ja.
Kann man nix sagen.
Ist jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig komplex
oder so? Kannst du jetzt nicht 3 Milliarden,
30 Milliarden Sachen mitmachen?
Finde ich ganz gut.
Gut, dann stöpseln wir doch mal
eine Festplatte dran.
Eine SSD stöpseln wir mal dran.
Wartet mal kurz, ich muss noch was holen.
Ich hab hier
eine billige
Mal gucken, da können wir gleich mal testen,
ob das Hotswap fähig ist.
Ich hab hier eine billige SSD.
ne SanDisk SSD plus
240 Gig
SATA
das ist bestimmt totaler Schrott, aber die funktioniert noch
die benutze ich normalerweise im USB Adapter
aber da ist nichts wichtiges drauf, den machen wir einfach platt
so, ich mach mal hier
Slot 1 auf, Wechselrahmen
hier, hört ihr es?
da ist er
jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken, wie man da eine SSD reinkriegt
wisst ihr, bin ich schon wieder zu dumm für
Push.
Steht da. Push und dann?
Ah.
Seht ihr, Leute? Ich weiß
nicht, wie man hier eine SSD reinkriegt.
In die...
In diese Rahmen.
Da müssen wir uns, würde ich sagen, mal die Hilfeseite auf der Webseite angucken.
Weil es gibt nichts zum Schrauben hier.
Also zum Schrauben ist hier eher vermutlich...
Na doch, gibt was zum Schrauben.
Ich glaube, doch, ich glaube,
SSDs muss man schrauben, Leute.
Hier sind genau solche Abstände
für die Schrauben.
Aber das passt nicht.
Die SSD passt nicht.
Da müssen wir jetzt mal
auf das Manual auf der Webseite gucken.
ukraine wir haben es doch irgendwie noch plus ja
manual
pro manual
4800 plus okay gibt es noch dies
ist das ach ddx p 4800 plus 4800 pro gibt es auch ganz oben ja ich lese
so lässt immer von unten also handbuch produkte dokumentation in deutsch
ok da guck mal wie das funktioniert
muss es ja ein paar bilder für geben all out hard drive tray ok install 3,5 hart ist das will ich
ich ja nicht. Ich will eine SSD
installieren.
Install 3,5
Hard
Screwdriver required.
Okay. Remove the pin.
What? Moment. Was? Was?
Was? Was? Wie? Wo?
Pin?
Was zum Teufel? Welcher Pin?
Da ist kein Pin.
hängen geblieben oder was?
Remove the pin on the right side
of the tray. Remove the
pin at the end of the tray using
the tray key.
Ah!
Man muss auf die
richtige Seite gucken.
Okay, also das, was soll ich
jetzt machen? Den tray key
removing. Mach ich jetzt.
Moment, mit dem Schraubstelz geht es schon mal nicht, brauche ich den anderen.
Okay, ich habe ihn removed und jetzt?
install hard drive flip the tray to its back and the line of four empty crew space at the bottom
place the pin into the hole on the other side
Ja, das ist absolut next level, das Ding.
Okay, gut.
Jetzt muss ich die SSD hier reinmachen.
Hier, da braucht man Schrauben für, verstehe.
Gut, da war doch so ein Beutel.
Oh, nee, jetzt hätte ich das nicht wegschmeißen sollen.
Wo ist es denn hier?
Da war so ein Beutel mit Schrauben dabei, ne?
Ja, hier mache ich mal kurz auf.
Also, das fände ich viel schöner.
hätten sie da auch eine mechanische Variante
und kein
Schraubengeschraube für SSDs.
Das finde ich immer...
Bäh.
Okay, so.
Gib mir mal eine Schraube hier raus.
Zack.
Schraube.
Jawoll.
Ist drin.
Schraub, Schraub, Schraub.
erste schraube ist drin zweite schraube geht auch noch rein das reicht mehr muss
ich dann ein festschrauben zwei schrauben unten und gut ist und sind
sie nicht alle vier dinger da rein fummeln
ok hups den trägers mikrofon gehauen
Okay, SSD ist drin.
Top.
Dann schauen wir mal, ob das Ding in irgendeiner Art und Weise Hotswap-fähig ist.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Also es liegt jetzt ja weniger an TrueNAS,
mehr an dem Ugreenas.
übrigens ich sehe das hat vorne leds finde ich auch sehr spannend die leds zeigen aktuell nichts
an aber ich glaube ich habe gesehen auf linux seite gibt es die möglichkeit die leds anzusteuern das
muss ich mir mal speichern das machen wir vielleicht dann im nächsten stream ukraine
das led steuern so mal gucken aha sdb wurde erkannt exzellent da machen wir
jetzt gerade mal wenn wir dabei sind die idee gleich def
Keine Idee.
ID.
IF gleich.
DEF.
Zero. Gibt es da, gab es da kein.
OF gleich.
DEF.
STB.
Oh doch, tatsächlich. Okay, das funktioniert wohl.
Ähm.
Block Size 4K.
Count gleich. Ja, 1000.
So, jetzt ist die Festplatte
theoretisch leer.
DEF, STB.
genau std ssd ist leer also da war doch mal mal gucken wie man mit schulers
jetzt desks anlegt schulers atmen
also data sets create pool machen wir jetzt ja nein wir machen das single disk
cool ist ja also es ist mal wurscht encryption interresting
und encryption ist was soll pool level and chips oder pleite durch storage pool
oder des in the pool it applies to data ja okay das weiß ich aber encryption
kann man jetzt nicht lassen wir es mal aus zum test layout mirror mit nur einer disk top breite
number of the devs
next
lock optional brauchen wir nicht next option next cash next metadata optional
next die application aber garantiert nicht an next at least one data vd ist
required
habe ich doch oder muss ich sagen stripe
Ich brauch Stripes an, ne?
Ja, ja.
Ja.
Create Pool.
Yes.
Was hat er hier drin?
No Redundancy. Ja, ich weiß.
Ich weiß.
mach mal keine panik da kommt uns das ganze doch jetzt immer an als apps
containers experimente select pool enable containers tools main default network
bridge
Okay.
Mal schauen, was das jetzt da treibt.
Pausierungschamp.
Okay.
Create new container.
Ist das jetzt so eine Art LXC-Container oder was?
Ist das jetzt ein LXC-Container?
Kein Docker-Container, stell's?
Also quasi so eine Art Container wie eine VM?
Okay, probieren wir mal aus.
Blub.
Image.
Debian.
Demian Trixi selects
Ja, no limit no limit no limit Disks
Ich habe keine ahnung was der von mir will
Create dataset
Was will der in der Auswahl hier von mir?
Ach, hier ist der Pool, oder was?
Ach so.
Create data set.
Blub.
Okay, okay, okay.
Destination.
Specify the container file as a path where the disk will be mounted.
Ach so.
Ich kann es auch ganz ohne Disk machen.
Dann landet es auf dem Root-File-System, oder was?
Okay, mal gespannt.
Proxies, Network.
Use default Network Settings.
Das ist Nutted, oder?
Das finde ich ein bisschen unintuitiv irgendwie.
USB-Devices brauchen wir nicht, GPU-Devices brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht.
Okay.
Wie kann ich mich jetzt da irgendwie dran attachen?
Shell.
Okay.
Jetzt sind wir im Debian-Container.
Warte mal.
Upt.
Install.
Wird.
What?
Wir gucken jetzt mal, was es ist.
Wird.
What?
LXC.
Ah ja.
Oh, das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Das heißt, Trunas kann jetzt LXC-Container, wenn man quasi ein komplettes Betriebssystem braucht,
Docker-Container und VMs.
Damit hast du ja wirklich alles abgedeckt.
Damit kann es sogar eins mehr als Proxmox.
Aber ich glaube, das Handling ist in Proxmox deutlich schöner.
Für Virtualisierung LXC-Container.
Aber gucke, das finde ich gut.
Das finde ich gut, dass sie das auch unterstützen.
Manchmal hätte man halt gerne ein komplettes Betriebssystem,
aber will nicht unbedingt eine VM haben.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut, dass es das gibt.
Finde ich nice.
So.
Das hängt hinter irgendeinem Nut oder so.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Vielleicht nicht so dolle.
Finde ich das vielleicht hier, wenn ich unter Network gucke?
Da haben wir unterschiedliche Bridges.
Nee.
Bridge Setup geht hier schon mal irgendwie mit drüber, oder?
Doch.
Kann ich hier vielleicht eine Bridge adden?
Type?
Ah, Bridge.
Brrrr 1.
Die Fans.
Meine...
Was?
meine bridge braucht keine ip bridge members ja okay da kommt man auch noch
anlegen dass das okay finde ich gar nicht mal so übel
ich finde die berechtigung bei openmedia war nicht gar nicht so übel
Wie war das?
No nix.
Ah.
Ach so.
Dann addet man direkt die Netzwerkkarte hier.
Und dann kriegt man auch eine externe IP.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ah.
Finde ich sehr schick gemacht.
Gefällt mir ehrlich gesagt ganz gut.
Ja.
Testweise und OpenSSH Server drauf.
Ja, und jetzt sagen wir hier
SSH
192.1.1.7
Zack, und schon Funks.
Fix SSH.
Ja, ja.
Und schon können wir uns drauf verbinden.
Also könnten wir, wenn wir einen User drauf hätten.
Haben wir nicht.
Aber finde ich nicht schlecht.
Ehrlich gesagt, ja.
Passwd root
Mal gucken ob root passwort überhaupt erlaubt ist
Ist nicht erlaubt etc ssh sshd config
Permit root login yes
System ctl restart sshd
und soll schon sind und konnte unserem container drauf zwar auch nicht sonderlich sichere art und
auch als gut vielleicht nicht das bett aber es funktioniert finde ich eigentlich ganz cool
ehrlich gesagt aber wie schnell das jetzt ist ab install ipad ipad 3 ipad 3 minus s
Ah, ich hab schon wieder geschlossen
CD, Desktop, CD
CD, iPerf
iPerf
117, gell
Performance
Ich mein, da ist jetzt nichts großartiges dazwischen
Ist okay
Naja
Ja, kann man sich wieder beschweren
Inkus, das kenne ich
Ist das nicht das von Amazon?
Ne, das war Firecracker
Das von Amazon, gell
Inkus ist wieder was anderes
Ne, Inkus ist das von den Ubuntu Leuten
Das ist das neue LXC, oder?
LXD, das neue LXD
Ist das, das ist doch
Inkus ist doch dieses Ubuntu Zeug
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander
Das kenne ich, ja genau, das ist hier
Das neue LXD
Ja
Eigentlich ganz cool
So
Also das, die Funktion
Finde ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht schlecht
Ganz ehrlich, hat was
Ich finde es auch gut, dass die Docker-Container
VMs und
LXC-Container unterstützen
Das ist nice
Stop, clean, leave, force, shut down, now, bam
Finde ich gut, gefällt mir
So
Angeblich kann das aber
Docker-Compose
Wie geht das?
Okay, so schon mal nett.
Also angeblich kann
TrueNAS Docker Compose
Files
ins
Custom App.
Custom App gibt es hier angeblich.
Seht ihr das hier?
Jetzt choose the pool.
Kann man auch machen. Main.
Choose.
Cover.
Ah, install via YAML.
Ach so.
Okay, das finde ich jetzt nicht so schön.
Ich habe gedacht, man kann dem Ding vielleicht
ein Git-Repo geben oder sowas.
Copy-Paste von Yammel.
Composes da drin.
Ich weiß
nicht.
Das wäre cool, wenn das über
ein Git-Repo gehen würde.
Weil das hier so
Embedded in dem Editor und so.
Ach, ich weiß.
Das ist jetzt nicht so geil.
Jetzt nehmen wir uns mal eine Git-Repo.
Was zum Teufel war dann das da, was ich da gerade
gesehen habe eben?
Continuity.
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll, aber es ist
was für unsere
Ayaya-Fans.
Matrix Server.
MonkaS, Alter.
So.
Install.
Kann ich nicht noch eine ältere Version installieren?
Configuration.
Ich hätte eigentlich gerne
die, das mit
SQLite Datenbank.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Root-URL.
Ach so.
Dann brauche ich jetzt noch irgendeinen Proxy davor oder sowas.
Oder wie?
Keckel.
Punkt.
invalid format character oder muss das http doppelpunkt
ach so
oblich ort und haus vor external access ja number 30 142 ok aus type is
ja alles hier dran das ist okay das reicht publish port ssh port das
brauche jetzt nicht ich will es ja nur ausprobieren networks
das glaube ich brauche nicht zertifiziert schulers ach so man kann da sogar zertifikatssachen
drüber managen ja
so was will er jetzt hier also sonderlich intuitiv finde ich das jetzt
hier ehrlich gesagt nicht konflikt acs brauche nicht data neues data set okay
das mit der macht alles neue zfs data sets limit cpu install
gefällt mir nicht so richtig muss ich sagen ohne dass ich jetzt direkt den finger darauf legen
könnte.
Aber mir wäre
Docker Compose Support fast lieber.
Also mit Docker Compose Support
meine ich jetzt, wo man nicht in YAML da rein kopieren
muss.
Am liebsten wäre es mir so,
ich installiere mir einen Git-Repo,
sowas wie das hier, einmalig,
mit so einer
Embedded YAML oder sowas, und dann
werde ich nur noch auf das Git-Repo verlinken.
Das wäre mir so am liebsten.
Also das hier gefällt mir nicht.
mit mit install via yaml und so wenn man wenn man hier sagen könnte
kompost jammel vom getriebe oder so dass da viel viel heißer apps running web
Bäm.
Guck mal, jetzt kann ich sogar sagen, SQLite, lul.
Aber Hauptsache, der startet jetzt Postgres.
Ist eigentlich immer noch Helm?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist es kein Single-Node-Kubernetes mehr,
sondern irgendwas Docker-Composed-basiertes oder so.
ich weiß es gar nicht kann man mal gucken ob wir hier drauf docker finden
locker ps ja locker stellt ist es
okay postpress passwort 123456 das da was eben angegeben habe oder wie
Instance Title...
Ah!
Administrator Account
Username Admin
Admin at
example.com
install
Was?
Wie?
Ja dann...
ok das was alter 123456789 123456789 install ist er jetzt zufrieden
ja ich mache ich werde es bei mir auch in zukunft mit doch neu machen weil ich auf dem
das aber es wäre geil wenn es das unterstützt weil die weniger zusätzliche sachen man managt
muss umso besser
ach das jetzt noch was aber hart ob drauf wichtig wichtiger tja wollte okay
man muss sagen die tools election diese da standardmäßig mitbringen
heißt die executable von ford geo immer noch gta ich weiß dass ein gta fork
chat irgendwas haben wir kaputt gemacht
Es ist broken.
Chat, wir haben es zerstört.
Es ist kaputt.
Das finde ich schon mal nicht so geil.
Restart App
Und jetzt?
Postchamp
App UR
Natschat, wir haben es kaputt gemacht
Ich glaube
Das ist alles noch nicht so
Geil
Na gut
Das hat mich jetzt noch nicht so komplett überzeugt
installieren wir mal was einfacheres sagt man was simples gibt es hier irgendwie so ein hello world oder sowas
Irgendwas simples nx hello world nx proxy manager ok den kommen wir
Engine X Proxy Manager Plus.
Was ist denn das?
A fork of Engine X Proxy Manager.
Das Fork ist...
Warum braucht man das da?
Oh, hat sich wohl einiges getan.
jeder installiert engine x proxy manager plus
mpm munkers im sonja ja sollen wir alles recht sein alles gut so wir lassen alles
die fault lassen alles die fault aus network beim to the house network
Timezone LA, was juckt mich die Timezone?
Timezone ist doch komplett egal.
du bist dann übrigens noch einen sammler anlegen und sowas so npn pm plus web
P.U.I.
Container ist nur ein. Gut.
Ach, guck mal, hier kann man sich sogar Logs anzeigen
lassen von dem Container. Das fängt ja eigentlich ganz nice.
Ah.
Ja. Ja, warum nicht?
Was braucht der denn jetzt
so lang?
Was braucht der denn
jetzt da drei Stunden zum Starten?
Shell?
Hä?
so wirklich geil ist es nicht.
Also, der startet
zuerst mal gar nicht.
Wieder ein neues
Nas. Ne, das liegt schon über einen Monat hier bei mir rum.
Das wird auch
keine ablösung von minis forum das einfach nur bastel dann
also das jetzt ist es running das hat einfach so lange gebraucht
full name cute chat example punkt com 123456
Oh Gott, überall!
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 8, 9.
Safe.
Also.
Sieht aus wie Nginx Proxy Manager.
Das ist aber alles immer noch per Docker.
Ja, ja.
Hier, guck, Nginx Proxy Manager.
So, hier können wir jetzt Gedöns machen.
Host, Proxy Host, Add Host.
Das will ich jetzt ja gar nicht machen.
Ich wollte nur mal was starten.
Okay, das funktioniert.
von Geo habe ich aus irgendwelchen
Gründen zerstört.
Keine Ahnung, was ich da getrieben
habe. Stoppen wir das Ganze mal.
Also diese Sache
mit den Apps hier.
Das ist
so
so semi-nice.
Also was ich richtig cool
finden würde ist, wenn ich
Was hab ich jetzt gedrückt?
Chat, wie bin ich denn jetzt dahin gekommen?
Custom App
Image
Ah ne, ich kann da auch kein
Ne, also was ich halt cool finden würde ist
Wenn ich ein Git-Repo
angeben könnte
hier wenn ich hier sagen könnte install jammel und dann hier url zu compose jammel das wäre
premium für mich das war nicht cool aber das ist anscheinend nicht supported was der unterschied
ist zwischen npm und zwischen nx proxima und plus das ist irgendein fort mit ein paar neuen features
Ich wusste bis eben auch nicht, dass das existiert.
Keine Ahnung.
Ah, kann es Let's Encrypt?
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Ach ja.
Cloudflare DNS.
Das finde ich gut.
Das finde ich gut, dass der auch für dich Let's Encrypt Zertifikate handeln kann.
Das gefällt mir.
Moment, mehr kann der nicht.
der kann nur cloud verletzt lauschen er kann beispielsweise kein parkbahn oder
sowas ist mir jetzt vielleicht mit ist mir bis sie wenig aber trotzdem
zumindest keiner cloud flair das schon mal gut laut der dns ich hoffe mal dass
der dns dns notifik dns challenge machen kann für letzten kopf das auf jeden fall
sehr praktisch
kannst du nicht ein docker management tool was geht kann ins ja ja ich kann
doch neu oder so ins studio das funktioniert schon aber dann braucht man halt diese funktion
hier auch wiederum nicht so jetzt in seiner vm ja klar können kann man das machen aber wenn es
so eine funktion gibt ist halt nice wenn ihr die basic sachen kann die man braucht da muss
man weniger sachen selbst managen ich muss gerade mal chat lesen und würde irgendwas übersehen
So, dann machen wir mal eine 4M
Gucken wir mal
Available Memory
4,62 Gig
Das könnte knapp werden, Leute
Add
Guest Operating System
Linux
Name Omega Kekl
System Glock
Local, ja okay
Boot Method UEFI
Shutdown Timer
Start on Boot, ne
Enable Display, ja okay
Bind
Äh
Ach, es gibt keine Webkonsole.
Sehe ich das richtig? Es gibt keine Webkonsole.
Ja gut, das finde ich jetzt semi-geil.
ok das ist doch gibt es virtual cpu kurs frets aus bei 3
memory size gibt es keinen drop down zur auswahl 1024 next disks create new disk wird
I.O.
Main?
Fragezeichen.
Bei Android geht das aber über eine Webkonsole.
Das ist zwar VNC, aber da brauchst du kein Passwort,
weil da stand ja explizit, es geht nicht über einen Browser.
Okay, ja.
Virtuoso ist das richtige Netzwerk.
Trust Guest Filters brauchen wir nicht.
Installation Media brauchen wir auch nicht.
GPU.
Ensure Display Device.
Ah.
Okay, das geht nicht.
Confirm.
Okay, Save.
Echt ein bisschen ratlos gerade so.
Start.
Display.
Okay, es gibt wirklich keine Webkonsole.
Ja, das ist echt mies.
Das ist wirklich mies.
Und dann steht noch nicht mal die IP.
Also, das ist so wirklich sehr behelfsmäßig, ja.
Ich installiere mir mal einen VNC.
Was gibt es hier? Tiger VNC oder sowas.
Oder was ist denn da?
Ich habe ewig kein VNC mehr verwendet.
Serial Shell?
Ne, das ist was anderes.
Das ist irgendwas anderes.
Irgendwas anderes.
Keine Ahnung.
Was ist denn die beste VNC?
Tiger VNC, oder?
Hab ich früher immer benutzt.
VNC.
Viewer.
4.000.
Moment.
Ist das doch jetzt die richtige Shell?
Warte mal, jetzt bin ich...
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Restart.
Der restartet nicht.
Wie gut.
Power off.
Start.
Ups, ah.
Was? Domain is already running.
Okay.
Ja, das ist ja abfuck.
Wie komme ich jetzt ins BIOS?
zum Netzwerk booten.
Ähm.
Das ist
tatsächlich etwas
für Pega.
Edit.
Kann ich ihm sagen, mach Netzwerk
boot oder sowas.
Ich habe legit keine Ahnung, wie ich jetzt Netzwerkboot starten soll.
Meinst du, Control-Alt entfernen hier drin im VNC?
Ups.
Chat.
Äh, Chat, meine Maus hängt. Ich kann nichts mehr machen.
MonkaS?
Ich kann nichts mehr machen.
Okay, okay, okay.
Scheint wieder zu gehen.
Aber das...
Kann man jetzt hier vielleicht
Ctrl-Alt entfernen oder so senden?
Ey, das ist richtig krasser Abfuck, man
Alter, jetzt hängt es wieder
Jetzt kannst du komplett knicken, man
Ne, es hängt.
Es hängt mein komplettes...
Ich kann ja nicht mal Ctrl-Alt-Delete
mehr drücken.
Okay, jetzt sind wir wieder da.
Okay, Leute, das ist so ziemlich die abartigste VM-Handling,
was ich seit einer ganzen Weile gesehen habe.
Wie rebooted man eigentlich aus so Efishel?
How to reboot from Efishel.
Ich will rebooten vom Efishel.
Reboot vom Efi Shell
Das ist glaube ich zu advanced
Exit
Oh
Pog
Exit
gut manager was ist denn gut maintenance manager gut manager ja
man jetzt hier wir wollen pxe
warum es auch immer irgendwie aus irgendwelchen gründen zweimal gibt pxe bootform machen
Okay, Netzwerkboot geht aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht.
Oder doch? Geht doch.
Wie es das mit dem Trunas geht?
Ah, also ganz ehrlich, die Container-Funktion finde ich sehr nice, wie sie die gemacht haben.
die sachen für also die nxt container funktion finde ich sehr nice diese docker applications naja
auch nicht so geil
wir installieren als erstes mal debian da drauf und gucken ob das so funktioniert kann ich meinen
eigenen PXE-Installer
verwenden.
Stable auf die Disk
Debian.
Das funktioniert
zumindest.
An sich läuft es gut.
Also das, was ich bisher
benutzt habe, ist mir
etwas zu hakelig, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich habe aber noch gar nicht
die Kernfunktionalität von Netzwerk-Storage
ausprobiert.
Das ist ja das Eigentliche.
Okay, da sind wir.
Äh, 2...
15.
Debian
at
15.
Ach, ich kack, Noob.
Ich hab ja immer noch nicht mein SSH-Key hinzugefügt.
Okay, das machen wir
jetzt mal schnell.
Weil sonst sag ich das die nächsten 30 Male
noch hier SSH auf 55 war es war www.html.de da will ich hin genau da gibt es jetzt
irgendwo configs.
Config.
Da sind die Keys.
Genau. Und da
muss jetzt auch noch
ssh
max-add-cache-os rein.
Gut. Und bei der Gelegenheit
können wir jetzt...
Achso.
Wie reboote ich
Ey, das ist wirklich eklig, dass man hier keine Tastatur hat
Wie reboote ich denn das Ding jetzt gescheit
Wenn ich mich nicht einloggen kann
Gibt es hier vielleicht
Gibt es hier im Docker vielleicht sowas
Hier, Restart kann ich jetzt machen
Oh ne, da geht VNC auch zu
Boah, das ist wirklich ganz eklig
Da muss man jetzt auch noch schnell sein
Was zum Teufel geht mit meinem
Alter
Was macht mein VNC hier
VNC bleibt auch nicht offen
Wenn man restartet
Okay man kriegt keine
Keine richtige Shell
Und mal hier restart
Serial Shell
Da muss man jetzt
Mega schnell sein
Ich bin nicht schnell genug
Es gibt hier keine Shell
Kein Desktop
Also kein
Display-Geschichten.
Wenn ich jetzt hier sage,
ich kann ja auch keine Tastendrücke
senden und sowas.
Ich weiß nicht.
Also ich will jetzt ja im Endeffekt nochmal
Netzwerk booten, aber das geht halt einfach nicht
gescheit.
Oh, Edit.
Man kann jetzt hier auch nicht sagen,
gute gute ins boot menü oder sowas das heißt ich muss jetzt allen ernstes ich muss jetzt sagen restart
dann muss ich mega schnell sein yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
Es escape escape escape escape
alter das kann doch nicht euer ernst sein
Das ist doch nicht normal
Das Ding braucht eine Webkonsole. Fertig, aus.
Wie kann man Virtualisierungsgedöns anbieten ohne eine Webkonsole?
Also das finde ich mies. Das finde ich echt mies.
Das gefällt mir überhaupt nicht, Virtualisierung mit Junas.
Kann er heute nochmal starten?
Ist auch ein Nasso und kein Hypervise.
Aber die bieten es an.
Wenn sie es anbieten, soll es auch gescheit funktionieren.
Macht ja keinen Sinn
Irgendwas einzubauen und das ist nicht usable
So, wenn ich es jetzt richtig gemacht habe
Nochmal Debian neu installiert habe
Dann müsste ich mich auch per SSH drauf verbinden können
Äh
Wo ist jetzt das Problem?
Also irgendwie ist das ein bisschen hakelig, diese ganze Virtualisierungsgeschichte.
Jetzt hängt das irgendwie nachdem Debian installiert wurde.
I don't know.
Keine Ahnung.
Skip.
Ja, das ist, das ist glaube ich Mist.
Virtualisierungsstells.
Ne, das, das, das, das gefällt mir nicht.
Also.
Ach, guck mal, jetzt bootet er.
Er hat es doch noch gecheckt.
Ey.
Okay, KDE kommt damit auch nicht klar.
Wir schauen jetzt nochmal, ob ich mich per SSH einloggen kann.
Das Container...
Witzigerweise ist das Experimental bei Containern, finde ich, richtig gut, ne?
Bei 4Ms.
Fix SSH, Ben.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Du sollst dich nicht als Max verbinden, du sollst dich als Demian verbinden.
Okay, jetzt funktioniert's. Okay, nachdem ich meinen SSH-Key hinzugefügt habe, alles gut.
Okay. Ja, jetzt haben wir hier unsere Demian-VN. Also wenn's läuft, läuft. Dann ist's okay.
das kann auch mal kurz was schauen ipad wie es mit wie die wie die performance virtualisiert ist
3-5
bisschen minimal langsamer aber vollkommen fein besser als diese schritt ried netzwerkkarte
So, so, so, das ist top.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Excellent.
Find ich nice. Gefällt mir.
Aber die Virtualisierungsfunktion
gefällt mir nicht.
Ne, ne.
Das ist nicht so geil.
das ist in der tat eher schrott
also virtualisierung ohne webkonsole
die weißes usb passt zu pc passt zu
Guck mal, ich kann meine Grafikkarte
durchreichen hier.
Ah ne, das mag er ja nicht.
Wenn ich die Grafikkarte durchreiche,
das kann er ja nicht ab, oder?
Checkt er das, wenn ich die Grafikkarte
durchreiche?
Äh.
Moment, ich hab jetzt die Grafikkarte
durchgereicht vom Host.
Das kackt doch
gleich ab, oder?
Das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren.
Noch ist Jonas da.
Noch bootet es auch.
Okay.
Ist es da?
Guck mal, die Grafikkarte wurde durchgereicht.
Ähm
Siehst du was auf dem KVM?
Sehr gute Frage
Äh
Ne
Ich seh aber auch nicht mehr den Host
Ich seh gar nix drauf
Ich seh gar nix
Können die nicht sogar S-A-I-O-V?
Können die das?
Okay, das ist interessant
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren, das ist eine gute Frage
Intel iGPU S-A-I-O-V
Können die das?
Oh, cool
check if srv ist enabled das ist natürlich cool
okay man das braucht bios support und alles jetzt bios müssen wir noch mal gucken
Interessant, das probieren wir dann nochmal aus. Mich würde mal interessieren, aber sag doch mal,
wenn ich jetzt Ulama oder so starte, so wirklich von dieser Intel GPU profitiert das doch nicht,
oder? Das ist doch quasi fast so gut wie nix, diese Intel GPUs. Da krieg ich dann vier Tokens
die sekunde oder so ist wir bleiben aber netzwerkkarten ok beim netzwerk karten
ist ein bisschen einfacher zu erklären aber im prinzip ist es bei grafikkarten
ähnlich wenn du eine netzwerkkarte in deinem server trainer hast also sagen
wir sagen wir du machst virtualisierung ja du hast du hast oder installiert die
einen server zum virtualisieren dann willst du ja dass sowohl dein host als auch alle vms per
netzwerk kommunizieren können so die standardlösung unter linux ist die die dein host dann virtualisierung
ist der hat die netzwerkkarte der hat den netzwerkkarten treiber und alle vms werden
über eine bridge angeschlossen und eines der bridge interfaces ist halt deine
netzwerkkarte deine richtig physische netzwerkkarte also es hängt dann alles
an der software bridge dran so weit so weit so klar fragezeichen also das ist
die default geschichte du hast dann du hast ein software bridge mit deiner
netzwerkkarte drin und an dieser netzwerkkarte hängt dann dein host dran
deine ganzen vms dran und alles genau so und wenn du jetzt SAIOV machst
kannst du aus einem Netzwerkgerät 16 Netzwerkgeräte machen, die du dann per PCI-Passthrough an VMs durchreichen kannst.
also du hast dann quasi virtualisiert so auf auf auf hardware ebene hast du deine netzwerkkarte
60 du hast aus einer echten hardware netzwerkkarte 16 virtuelle gemacht die du dann durchreichen
kannst eine vm pci express pci passt und die vm denkt du hast pci eine netzwerkkarte durchgereicht
das hat den vorteil du musst nicht mehr über die software bridge gehen ja die performance ist viel
viel besser die performance ist viel besser und viel weniger cpu last die du verursacht
bei der bridge ist ja alles in software und bei srv kriegst du quasi 16 16 netzwerkgeräte
angezeigt die du dann per pc passwahl einer vms durchreichen kannst und so ist es also ist es
paar Grafikkarten im Endeffekt auch.
Bedeutet das nicht,
dass ich dann auf 16 VMs limitiert bin?
Ja, bist du. Aber es gibt
viele Geräte, die können bis zu
bis zu, was weiß ich, 128
SAIOV-Devices aus einer Karte
machen und sowas.
Ja.
Linux,
Intel,
GPU, SAIOV.
Ja.
Wild.
Ich glaube, das ist sehr advanced,
das jetzt
auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
How to.
Wir gucken noch mal ins Bios.
Oh, das, das, das
Aha, IOMO müssen wir noch einschalten
Okay
Ja, das können wir jetzt aber nicht gescheit
Weil
Wir können ja die Sachen in TrueNAS halt richtig editieren
Da müssen wir jetzt nochmal Proxmox drauf installieren
Anstatt TrueNAS
Und mal gucken, ob das funktioniert
Vorher will ich aber nochmal ins BIOS gucken
Und wir müssen jetzt auch mal die eigentliche
Funktionalität von TrueNAS mal ausprobieren.
So, machen wir jetzt nämlich mal hier Storage.
Ne, Shares.
Shares.
Windows Share Add.
Das finde ich ein schönes Interface hier übrigens.
Da weiß man gleich, was Sache ist.
Add Windows Share.
Looks like you don't have any users
who will be able to access this share.
Direct new user.
wie die können keine shares accessen oder wie na gut dann legen wir mal okay das max
heißt jetzt max sammer access ach wir können wir kommen aber wir können einfach hier sagen
edit sommer axis passwort macht bis jetzt ist doch gesetzt 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 6 messer passwort
attributes cannot be changed okay das ist wahrscheinlich für den eingebauten user geht
das nicht also user max samba axis 123456 1234 12356 will so anwalt auf dem nass testen das
finde ich übrigens mit android auch nicht so geil dass minis forum ist da ist da tatsächlich viel
nicer weil du bei den minis forum lassen intern usb stecker hast das hat er sein schein funktioniert
Okay. Shares?
Also erwartet euch jetzt nicht so viel
von der Performance, gell?
Sag ich gleich. Ich hab da ne billige SATA-SSD
drinne.
Main?
Create Dataset?
SMB.
Default Share?
Time Machine Share? Multi-Protokoll
Share?
What the fuck?
Default Share.
klingt gut.
Advanced Options.
Okay, save.
Do you want to configure
ACLs? No.
Das war's. Okay, das ist in der Tat
sehr easy.
Schauen wir mal.
Hier.
Max.
Okay, das ist in der Tat
einfachstes Samba Setup, was ich bisher gesehen
habe, bei irgendwelchen Nasslösungen.
Ach, du kannst mittlerweile von
NVMe starten. Haben sie das jetzt
hingekriegt bei Unraid?
Aber ich fand die Sache
mit dem USB-Stick und dann im Prinzip
Unraid lief ja von einem Re-Only
USB-Stick alles in den RAM. Fand ich vom
Ansatz her gar nicht schlecht. Da hast du dann
im Endeffekt halt einfach noch mehr Slots
freigehabt für Laufwerke.
hier kopieren 28 gig drauf
das legteil an meine ssd die wobei so lahm sollte die jetzt auch wiederum nicht sein
wir müssen mal kurz wir müssen mal kurz meine ssd benchmarken ob die wirklich so
beschissen ist okay weil das ist jetzt das ist jetzt hardcore beschissen
Ich hätte gedacht, wir kriegen irgendwie
200, 300 MB oder sowas
Was ist das denn?
Alter, WTF?
Okay, ist meine SSD echt so beschissen?
MNT
Main
smb
ok
habt install 4
p-sync
Okay, die SSD ist echt absoluter Schrott.
Ist die scheiße, Alter.
Ist die scheiße, Mann.
Wo hast du die gefunden?
Im Schrank?
Im Schrank habe ich die gefunden.
Ist die schlecht.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ist das schlecht, Alter.
Oh Mann, ist das schlecht.
Okay, machen wir es mal.
Synchron.
Okay, das ist ein bisschen besser.
Boah, ist das schlecht, Alter.
Ist das mies.
Okay, mal zum Abschrecken.
Ich sag euch, was das für eine SSD ist.
Das ist eine...
Oh, wie ging das nochmal? NVMe?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Dev?
SDA?
STB? Oh ne, keine Ahnung.
Linux Show SSD Infos.
LSPCI geht auch, ja.
Aber dann Minus Tree ist das?
ging das nicht dass man tree machen kann ach so seht ihr irgendwo sata ssd
bitte irgendwas
Ich nicht.
Ja, LSBLK bringt ja nichts.
Das ist ja...
SDB ist auf jeden Fall das Richtige.
LSHW minus Disk?
Ne, ich will das mit NVMe anzeigen.
Smart CTL.
Okay, Smart CTL geht auch.
Dev SDB.
Ja.
Das ist eine...
SanDisk SSD plus 240G.
Das scheint...
Ganz großer Schrott zu sein, das Ding.
Okay, Leute, die SSD ist so beschissen,
das muss ich jetzt nochmal anderweitig testen.
Wartet mal.
Also zumindest ein bisschen was,
ein bisschen was Besseres machen wir jetzt mal rein.
Also ich muss noch Mario Kart Musik neu starten.
Ich hab hier noch ne...
MX500.
Die müsste ein bisschen besser sein, okay?
MX500 machen wir jetzt rein
Ich mach mal hier
Das wieder raus
Jetzt muss ich wieder diesen komischen Krempel machen
Mit diesem
Mit diesem komischen Wechselrahmen hier
Also das ist
Also das ist ein Kacksystem
Mit dem Wechselrahmen für SSDs
Das ist wirklich mies
das ist jetzt auch noch ohne falle das ding mann
so ich schraube da jetzt die andere ssd noch ein zack
wenn das keine neue das ist keine neue die ist schon einige jahre alt aber
bisschen besser müsste die auf jeden fall seine man also so schlecht wie
dieses sandes ssd kann das ja auf gar keinen fall sein
ich habe leider keine nvm ist ich habe noch eine andere ich habe noch eine usb
die komme auch nehmen wenn wir okay wir testen das jetzt mal beides ich mache
jetzt immer die hier rein und ich mache jetzt die hier rein und dann zur not
nehmen wir die die andere per usb die usb ssd ist deutlich schneller
Was haben wir denn hier jetzt?
SDC haben wir jetzt.
Okay.
Tuners.
So, wie macht man das jetzt?
Ähm.
Wie lege ich jetzt nochmal neue Pools an?
Hier, Datasets.
Äh, wie lege ich denn einen neuen ZFS-Pool an?
Storage?
Unassigned Disks, okay
Create Pool
Äh
Fast
Warum ich random SSDs rumfliegen hab?
Naja, weil ich über die letzten, was weiß ich
15 Jahre oder so ein paar SSDs hatte
Ich schmeiß die ja nicht weg
Stripe
Okay, sehr gut
next next next next diesen wizard mag ich übrigens nicht da gefällt mir nicht
next next next create pool bam zack gib ihm okay das immer dann legen wir jetzt hier nochmal
shares an die lied die fall share fast smb
enable safe ich ganz ehrlich das setup von dem nass schert das finde ich sehr
gut gelöst das gefällt mir nicht nice
Warum liegt da eine Kekkelbin?
Die dürfte da eigentlich nicht liegen.
Ach, MNT.
MNT Fast SMB.
Die dürfte da eigentlich nicht liegen.
Das müsste jetzt...
Jetzt ist er durcheinander...
Das ist doch der Share von vorher.
Ja, aber das sollte nicht der Share von vorher sein, eigentlich.
Wir machen jetzt hier mal einen Fio drauf und gucken, wie schnell die SSD ist.
Okay, die ist ein bisschen besser, okay?
Ja, das kann man so lassen, denke ich.
Die ist dann doch ein bisschen zackiger.
Guck mal, das geht immer noch auf den alten Share, oder?
Das geht immer noch auf den alten Share
Muss ich
Muss ich Samba noch neu starten, oder so?
Oder hab ich einen Bug gefunden?
Oder habe ich einen Bug gefunden irgendwie?
Samba Stop.
Samba Start.
Wir können jetzt aber touch.blub.txt.
So, wenn wir die jetzt sehen.
Okay, gut, passt.
Jetzt ist es der richtige Share.
Ja.
Das ist okay.
Das ist im Prinzip genau das, was die SSD auch hergibt.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Excellent ist das, Leute.
Excellent.
Ja.
Also das ist ja das, was die SSD hergibt.
Und wir würden da auch mehr durch...
Wir kriegen damit auch 10 Gig Saturated.
bin ich mir relativ sicher wir können ja einfach um das war zu checken moment
ich habe hier ich habe ja noch eine noch eine usb ssd ich habe ein problem
ich brauche ein ordentliches usb 3 kabel aber ich habe hier gerade keins
hier vielleicht vielleicht ist da eins dabei lass mal kurz gucken ist da vielleicht eins dabei
da ist nur ein netzwerk und hdmi dabei
also ich brauche den usb c auf usb a so was habe ich hier gerade nicht rumliegen ihr vielleicht
Ah, hier.
Dann ziehe ich jetzt einfach die USB raus.
Nicht die USB, die KVM.
Wie komme ich auf eine USB?
Okay.
So, mal gucken, was hier die
schnellste
USB 3.2 ist. Das müsste recht zackig sein.
Okay.
Jetzt habe ich noch eine
andere SSD dran.
hier sandisk pro ist was stc stc ist die andere sda ist das jetzt okay fd minus l def st ja 2 t
2 terabyte sandisk extreme pro mksf x4 oder xfs ich will mal kurz gucken wie schnell das ding ist
ohne irgendwelche ZFS-Geschichten zu machen.
Was?
Hat kein XFS?
Ja, halt X4 meinetwegen.
Yes.
Ja, aber das ist eine ganz gute
SanDisk-USB-SSD.
Die gehen klar.
Mal gucken, wie schnell die jetzt ist über USB 3.2
und mal gucken, wie gut das Kabel überhaupt ist.
Das ist ja auch immer so ein Ding.
Ah, hier habe ich noch eins. Hier habe ich doch noch eins liegen.
Nee, das ist ein HDMI-Kabel.
Doch, doch, aber hier habe ich noch...
Ähm, hier habe ich ein gutes Kabel.
Mal gucken, wenn die SSD jetzt zu langsam ist,
schließe ich die mit einem anderen Kabel an.
Hier habe ich noch ein gutes USB-Kabel.
Wo auch so ein super, super Speed-Icon
und so drauf ist.
Okay.
MKD, MNT2.
Was?
Im kadir blubb ok mount def sda nach blubb
jo
Das liegt am Kabel jetzt aber.
Das ist USB 2 Speed.
Das liegt jetzt am Kabel, Leute.
Umount, blub.
ja an maunter mal please
da braucht es drei stunden um das ding zu anbauen so als ob man das gescheite kabel
dran das kabel ist halt schrott das ist halt usb 2 kabel gewesen es gibt ja usb c usb 2 kabel
die halt sonst nichts können von dem anderen Kram.
So, jetzt. Das ist aber ein ordentliches
Kabel. Zack.
Ich find's übrigens auch richtig räudig,
dass du bei USB-Kabeln immer nicht so genau
weißt, ob das jetzt schnell,
langsam, wie auch immer ist.
So, ist wieder da.
Mount.
Def, SDA, nach Blub, Blub,
Fio.
Das sieht doch schon besser aus, oder, Leute?
Das flutscht.
Ein Gig pro Sekunde ungefähr.
Plutsch Champ.
Das ist doch okay.
Unmount, plupp.
Gut, dann werden wir jetzt noch mal da ein...
machen jetzt wir machen jetzt ein stripe wir machen jetzt ein stripe zwischen der
ein ssd die 500 mb packt und der anderen die ein gig packt und bei einem stripe
müssten wir dann eigentlich mehr raus bekommen oder oder
Chat, nee.
Müssten wir nicht, oder?
Gestript über eine, die 500 kann,
über die eine, die 1000 kann.
Da sind wir immer noch bei 1000 limitiert.
Weil der muss ja warten, bis es auf beiden Seiten geschrieben wurde.
Glaube ich.
Keine Ahnung, probieren wir.
Wir probieren das jetzt einfach mal aus hier.
Storage.
Ähm.
Fast. Kann ich das löschen?
Remove.
Okay.
Was?
Ähm.
Ich würde gerne den Pool löschen.
Wie lösche ich einen Pool?
Export disconnect
Destroy data on this pool
Confirm
Okay
Create pool
Omega keg
Next
Layout stripe
Disk
Das da?
Wo kann ich denn die zweite Disk hinzufügen?
Achso.
Hä?
Äh.
So?
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Achso, ich muss es da reinziehen.
ok ich bin super verwirrt was das jetzt macht warum ist als ein vd ok safe and
go to review pool
Keine Ahnung, Alter.
Omega-Keg.
Zwei Discs.
Okay.
Omega-Keg oder MNT-Omega-Keg?
Bio.
Okay.
Wir sind wirklich limitiert.
Aber es sollte reichen,
Chat, es sollte reichen,
mal zu gucken, ob wir das Gigabit
gemaxed kriegen über Samba.
Das sollte, ups,
das sollte eigentlich zumindest mal reichen.
Shares,
Ad.
Übrigens, das Handling von Samba
Shares und das reine
ZFS Pool Handling,
finde ich sehr gut gelöst hier über Tunas.
In der Kerndisziplin scheinen sie
wohl ganz gut zu punkten.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich habe nichts gesagt, Leute.
Samba ist aber auch Abpack, ne?
Muss ich jetzt vielleicht extra ACLs?
Everyone full allowed.
Oh ne.
Okay, Service. Also das sollte...
Das sollte nicht sein.
Okay, jetzt geht's.
Also dass man dann Samma neu starten muss, ist schon ein bisschen cringe.
Ja.
Konstante 1 Gig
Da müsste aber eigentlich noch ein Ticken mehr gehen
Da müssten schon eher
So 1,2 oder so gehen
Also da haben wir jetzt
Das ist jetzt Samba
Was da ein bisschen limitiert anscheinend
es könnte übrigens auch an meiner netzwerk hat wobei keiner aber das ist schon mal okay damit
damit kann man echt leben das ist das ist fein so dass alles okay so was wollte ich jetzt noch
gucken bei bei junas irgendwas habe ich doch gerade noch gesagt weil ich ausprobieren will
was sagt was sagt die cpu lasst das ist eine gute frage dass man kurz checken wenn wir da
jetzt übertragen mit einem mit mit einem gigabyte pro sekunde der ist schon gut am
schaffen der ist schon gut am schaffen er ist schon ordentlich am arbeiten hier
Wir können auch noch mal ein bisschen was größeres kopieren
Wow
Jetzt hat gerade meine ganze Kiste geruckelt
Aber er ist schon gut ausgelastet
Der hat die ja schon ganz schön zu kämpfen
also das könnte jetzt tatsächlich ein bisschen cpu limitiert sein weil mit fio sahen kriegen
wir ordentlich 1,3 kriegen wir mehr durch also da sind wir jetzt nicht mehr vom festplatten
Speed limitiert. Da sind wir jetzt
Netzwerk, wahrscheinlich von
der Samba-Performance und der CPU-Performance
limitiert. Ist meine
Vermutung jetzt einfach mal, ja.
Weil
Disk ist schnell genug,
Netzwerk ist auf jeden Fall auch schnell genug.
Also Netzwerk müsste mehr drüber kriegen.
Okay.
Wichtige Frage.
Im Idle-Betrieb.
Jetzt haben wir
34 Watt.
Was ich jetzt machen werde,
Chat, ich ziehe jetzt
die SSD ab.
Ich stöpsel
die
zwei Festplatten wieder aus.
Es ist nur die
Onboard-SSD drin.
Und jetzt haben wir
23 Watt.
So.
Upt. Install.
Powertop.
Wir machen jetzt mal Betriebssystemseitige Optimierung.
Und dann gehen wir mal ins BIOS gucken.
Power, Top.
Nee, nee, nee.
Minus, Minus, Auto, Tune.
Jetzt sind wir runter auf 21,7.
Hat ungefähr 2 Watt gebracht.
Also, ohne BIOS-Optimierung.
Hat die Kiste 21,7, 22, es schwankt ein bisschen, ja.
21,7, 22 Watt Eidel.
Das ist jetzt nicht krass viel, das ist aber auch nicht gerade wenig.
Also es gibt Kisten, die kommen unter 10 Watt Eidel.
Problemlos, ja.
Also das ist jetzt nicht so geil.
Dann machen wir jetzt nochmal ein paar Optimierungen.
Wir schalten das Ding jetzt, wir rebooten jetzt mal.
Und gehen hier in unsere KVM.
Powertop zu empfehlen.
Ja und ne, manche Festplatten haben mit den SATA Power Settings, ups, das wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Manche Festplatten haben mit den SATA Power Settings Probleme.
Aber ansonsten ist es auf jeden Fall ein Versuch wert.
Du kannst mit Power Top eigentlich nichts kaputt machen.
Vielleicht im Fall Rebootest du, dann geht wieder alles.
Power Top persistiert auch standardmäßig.
Keine Power Settings.
Kannst du dich neu starten vielleicht so?
Sehr geehrter Herr Trunas,
bitte rebooten.
Er hat keinen Bock.
Seht ihr das, Chat? Der will nicht.
Nope, sagt er.
Vielleicht, weil ich ihm unter dem Arsch
die Festplatten weggezogen habe gerade?
Meinst du, damit hat er vielleicht Probleme?
Ich finde es aber immer doof,
wenn SSH-Zugang
schon ausgeschaltet wird
und das System danach nicht reboote.
Das finde ich immer richtig abartig.
Mir ist es lieber, sie schalten Netzwerk und SSH als allerletztes aus,
dass du noch drauf kannst
und zur Not Hard-Rebooten kannst.
Also ich glaube,
von alleine
reboote da nichts mehr.
Hard-Reboot. Ich drücke mal die Power-Taste.
Äh.
Da passiert nichts.
Ich drücke jetzt seit 10 Sekunden
schon die Power-Taste. Das interessiert das überhaupt nicht.
Ich glaube, da muss ich Stecker raus und rein machen.
Ach ja.
Okay.
Stecker raus.
Stecker rein.
HVM, verarsch mich nicht.
Der Stecker ist raus.
Genau, wollte gerade sagen, was zeigst du da für einen Mist an?
Chat, schön, dass ihr übrigens so zahlreich erschienen seid heute wieder.
Exzellent.
Falls ihr es noch nicht getan habt, würde ich mich natürlich auch über ein Follow von euch freuen.
Das ist immer exzellent.
Ich muss nur gerade mal die Schrauben einsortieren.
Heute läuft es zu glatt.
Ja, muss ja auch mal sein, oder?
Ah, F12.
Enter Setup.
So, wir haben hier
ein super bloated BIOS
jetzt.
So, wir stellen jetzt mal
das ein, was dieser Dude hier
vorschlägt.
aber kurz irgendwie so ich wollte das eigentlich irgendwie so machen ist es so
na ja schauen wir mal also ich so wie gucken einmal kurz durchs bios durch ja
so mal hier im schnell im schnell durchlauf weil das bios ist wirklich
mega umfangreich wenn man wenn man den den debug modus den debug modus
aktiviert. Ja, ansonsten ist es
nahezu nicht existent.
Also, gucken wir mal hier. Chipsets.
Security Boot. Hier gibt es nichts Spannendes.
Chipset.
Onboard LAN 2.
Das können wir schon mal disablen.
Weil, das ist
die 5-Gig-Netzwerk-Karte. Die brauchen wir nicht.
Die SSD ist die lassen wir an.
Guck mal, das Ding hat einen...
Wartet mal kurz. Irgendwas stimmt mit meinem Mikrofon nicht.
Oder mit meinem Headset.
So, exzellent.
Jetzt stimmt wieder alles.
Das Ding an den EMMC-Controller
ist mir gar nicht klar.
Ukraine, 4800
EMMC.
Ach ja.
Nur das normale.
Der Pro
hat das nicht.
dann lassen wir das aus das wäre ja cool wenn das auch in internen bisschen interne diskette
also usb und so das lassen wir auch alles eine sie states in ebel das schon mal gut wir müssen
übrigens gleich noch erinnert mich mal dran wir müssen gleich noch power top mal gucken ob der
überhaupt sie ist jetzt erreicht bei minis form kann man auch sogar einige
sachen einstellen was sie ist jetzt in ebel das ist wichtig für umsparen system
agent mag kannst du hier alles einstellen alter
WTF?
Alter!
The fuck?
Das kann ich doch jetzt nicht alles durchgucken.
Alter!
Das ist ja das...
Das ist das krasseste Bios, was ich je in meinem Leben gesehen hab.
Alter!
Boah!
Da brauchst du ja eine Suchfunktion
fürs Bios.
Und dann haben wir hier noch.
Hier geht es ja noch weiter.
Okay, also fangen wir mal an.
Wir machen mal das, was der Typ hier einstellt.
Also, Advanced, Performance.
Okay, also was sollen wir machen?
Advanced, wir sollen nach Advanced gehen.
Power und Performance.
Seht ihr das irgendwo, Leute?
Advanced, Power und Performance.
Power Settings.
Mitte.
Power und Performance.
CPU
C-States Enabled
Haben wir doch schon
Ah
C-States Enabled
Moment, der kann nur C1
Das ist aber schlecht
Package C-State Limit Auto
package sie state limit hier auto auto okay okay jetzt advanced advanced power settings
Ich sehe da gar nichts
Power
Power Settings
Ne
Enable ACPI Auto Configuration
Das sehe ich jetzt nicht
Hier ist nochmal Power Settings
Wir haben einfach zweimal
Das sind so viele Settings, dass es Menü zweimal gibt
Mit dem gleichen Namen
Okay
So, Advanced PCI-Subsystem Settings.
Okay.
PCI-Subsystem Settings.
PCI-Express Settings.
ASPM.
Ja, das ist dieses PCI-Express Power Management.
ASPM Support.
Auto.
External Synch.
Was auch immer.
Chipsets Disable.
Okay.
Jetzt soll ich gehen zu
Chipset
System Agent
Configuration
PCI Express
PCI Express Configuration
PCI Port
1 bis 3
Alter, wie viele Settings gibt es denn hier?
ASPM
LOSL1
Obviously, was sonst?
Okay.
Chipset.
PCHIO-Configuration.
PCI-Express-Configuration.
Was?
Nochmal?
Ähm.
PCI Express
Rootport X.
Und dann auf ASPM
Auto. WTF,
Mann. Also, wer soll
dann da durchblicken?
Aber ich meine, es ist auch
Advanced BIOS. Das ist nicht für die Kack-Noobs
wie uns. Das ist für die richtigen Experts.
Okay, da ist ausgeschaltet.
Auto.
Okay, und dann sollen wir checken.
Okay, das war's.
Das war's.
Save,
Change, Save Configurations
and Reset.
Schauen wir mal,
wie viel der jetzt braucht.
Warum steht hier unten Watch?
Chat, was meint ihr?
Eben hatten wir mit Power Top Auto-Tune
hatten wir so 22 Watt Idle.
Was meint ihr? Bringt das jetzt viel?
Oder was meint ihr? Wie viel Watt sparen wir?
Gar nichts.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Schoda,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Zum Strom sparen brauchst du aber
auch noch die L1-States. Die waren noch
auf disabled. Was, wo, wie?
Was war disabled?
Ich hab doch alles auf L0
und L1 eingestellt.
Wo war da noch was disabled?
SebiDev,
danke schön für den Sub.
Auch nicht gesehen, Freund.
Valeni, der Patri auch.
Greifilein, Xbersk,
Steinadler.
Exzellent.
Ja, wo da?
Ey, der Spios hat 30.000 Einstellungen.
So.
Also. SSH.
Äh.
Er ist zumindest
noch nicht gebootet. Also das Booten geht wirklich
nicht sonderlich schnell.
Okay.
Wir gucken jetzt gleich.
also ich gucke jetzt mal drauf leute 18 18 watt haben wir jetzt 18,4 18,1 17,9
das hat auf jeden fall ein bisschen was gebracht also vier warte jetzt
eingespart power top machen wir jetzt noch mal
Power, Top, Auto, Tune.
Ja, Sudo.
Okay, das hat jetzt nichts gebracht.
Das hat jetzt nichts gebracht.
Wir sind weiterhin auf 18.
Da gab es nicht mehr viel zu tunen.
Aber immerhin.
Immerhin.
Nordic, danke schön für den Sub.
Immerhin, das ist schon mal ganz praktisch.
Ich gehe gleich noch mal ins Bios gucken.
Wir schauen gerade noch mal, wenn wir
Power Top machen,
in welchen Idle
Idle Stats
C3
Sollten Intel CPUs nicht runtergehen
bis C10?
Der geht maximal
in C3.
aber immerhin ist ja auch schon mal was
also die cpu geht in den niedrigsten power state die sie kann
mehr als c3 gibt es nicht vielleicht unterstützen die bayou queen da irgendwie auch nicht mehr
sieht nicht so als hätte power top was gemacht
ja anscheinend anscheinend haben die nicht alle power states da drin
ok dann gehe ich noch einmal ins bios und guckt mir das einfach der axel da geschrieben hat
also das hier können wir wieder zu machen
F12
Alter, Boote, please
So, also wo meintest du jetzt?
Chipset?
Dahin, PCIe Configuration
Das da?
Oder wo? Hier?
Ach hier
L1 Substates
L1 Low
Du meinst die Dinger muss ich doch einschalten
Äh
Ich weiß nicht was das
L1 Low
Dios
Okay
Man muss denn sogar
Disablen, dass es funktioniert
Wie kannst du eigentlich von einem PC
Das ist eine KVM Kiste
Das ist eine
Komet Pro
KVM.
Komet.
So ein Ding ist das.
So ein Teil.
Du schließt das NAS an.
Per USB und HDMI.
Und dann kannst du es
über den Browser steuern.
Sehr angenehm.
Und deutlich günstiger als
Enterprise-Lösungen davon.
Ich habe ja noch so eine Enterprise-KVM.
Eine alte, ausrangigere Enterprise-KVM-Lösung,
die ich mal bei eBay gekauft habe.
Die hat aber nur einen VGA-Anschluss.
Also das Ding ist schon ganz gut.
Gibt es auch noch ein paar andere.
Ja, JetKVM, NanoKVM, PiKVM.
Und auch der Hersteller hat mehrere.
Aber so 100 bis 200 Euro musst du da schon ungefähr mit rechnen.
So, vielleicht könnten wir gucken jetzt nochmal.
Können wir irgendwas bei CPU-Configuration vielleicht noch einschalten?
Gibt es hier irgendwas?
Hier sehe ich jetzt nichts von CPU-Configuration.
Alter, wie viel Scheiß man da einstellen kann.
What the fuck, man?
Und da soll da irgendjemand durchblicken, was das überhaupt alles ist?
Also, aber jetzt mal ernsthaft, Chat, oder?
Das ist, glaube ich, das krasseste BIOS, was ich jemals gesehen habe in meinem Leben.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht,
Aber so ein umfangreiches Pierce habe ich noch nie im Leben gesehen.
Noch nie.
Okay, Onboard Audio schalten wir noch aus.
Brauchen wir nicht.
THC Configuration, keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Äh, was auch immer.
I Square C?
What?
Ich hinterfrag das mal nicht weiter.
ISH is not available.
Okay.
Wart mal dran.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was die Settings sein sollen.
was auch immer das alles ist
ok advanced cpu configuration turbo mode
ja geil das mehr gibt es da nicht
SATA Configuration
brauchen wir nicht
Power Settings brauchen wir nicht
Watcher hatten wir
IT8613 Super I.O
ok keine Ahnung
Hardware Monitor ja wunderbar
Network Stack
NVMe Configuration
OEM Items
Connectivity Configuration
was
Bluetooth
CPU-Configuration.
Aha.
Efficient Core Information.
Performance Core Information.
C6.
CPU Flex Ratio.
Hardware Prefetcher.
Virtualization ist aktiviert.
BIST ist ausgeschaltet.
Was auch immer BIST ist.
IS Enabled.
Okay, mehr mit C-States kann man da nicht einschalten.
Power & Performance, CPU, Boost Performance, Turbo Mode, Speed Shift.
Ey, so ein krasses BIOS.
CPU, VR Settings, Untermenüs mit Untermenüs.
Siehst du jetzt, guck mal hier.
Hier haben wir siehst du jetzt. Enabled.
Enhanced E-States.
Aber mehr geht hier.
Mehr geht nicht.
Package C-State Limit.
Wollen wir das einfach mal auf C10
schalten und gucken, ob es irgendwas bringt?
Custom P-State Table
Ah, ey
Da werd ich nie durchblicken
Platform Settings
Pseudo G3
PMIC
VCCIO
Alles klar, Alter
Das Bios ist so advanced, da wird noch nicht mal der Bauer durchblicken.
Weil der kennt ja auch hauptsächlich mit irgendwelchen Overclocking-Settings aus.
Ist schon...
sehr heftig.
Nochmal PCI Express Settings.
Gen 2.
Nochmal Network Stack.
Können sie echt nicht entscheiden.
CSM?
Ist disabled?
Okay, Leute.
Ich lasse jetzt meine Finger vom BIOS weg, damit
Save gut ist.
Du meinst, dass 80% der Settings auf der Hardware nichts bewirken?
Ja, vielleicht. Keine Ahnung.
Möglich.
Aber die wichtigsten Sachen werden wahrscheinlich defaultmäßig schon auf dem korrekten Wert sitzen.
Green.
Also eine Sache, die mir auch bei
Trunas nicht wirklich gefällt, ist aber nicht so
richtig relevant, ist die
Bootgeschwindigkeit. Die Bootgeschwindigkeit
ist ziemlich lahm. Guckt euch das mal an.
Wie lahm das Ding bootet.
Sleepge,
Bettge, macht er gerade.
Also die Bootgeschwindigkeit ist wirklich ganz unterirdisch schlecht.
Aber die Settings im BIOS haben noch nichts mit der Bootgeschwindigkeit von TrueNAS zu tun.
So, jetzt sollte er eigentlich wieder da sein.
Nun ja!
Nun ja, also.
Was will er hier?
Warning!
Ja, ja, bla bla.
Im Enterprise zählt ja auch Stabilität
Ey, bin ich dabei, ja
Wenn das tatsächlich so ist
Mein Debian zum Beispiel
Bootet deutlich schneller
Auch mit mehr Sachen installiert
Und, wobei, das ist ja glaube ich
Sogar ein Debian unter der Haube, oder?
ETC
Ist es nicht?
Äh, was gibt es da?
ETC LSB Release?
Ne, Unaim
lsp release so war das okay debian bookworm
also noch kein trick sie
So, was gibt's denn sonst noch auf
Trunas zum angucken?
Chat, fällt euch noch irgendwas ein, was wir uns unbedingt
anschauen müssen?
Also wir haben jetzt Shares ausprobiert,
ZFS, Poolhandling und sonst was
ausprobiert, Containers,
Ach ja!
Ich weiß was.
Hast du Docker Compose mal versucht?
Nee.
aber es gibt ja auch keine
Docker-Compose-Unterstützung,
die ich benutzen möchte.
Also du hast,
die einzige Möglichkeit, die du hier hast,
ist, dass du sagst,
install via YAML. Da kannst
ein Docker-Compose hinhauen,
aber das musst du jetzt immer inline
in diesem komischen Editor hier pflegen.
Das ist ganz abartig.
Docker-Service
not running. Okay.
Warum nicht?
Ach so weil ich die
Max sehr schlau ich habe ja gerade die die die die festplatten rausgezogen
Sollte ich vielleicht mal wieder rein machen
Und dann muss ich noch mal rin booten
Okay, hat das jetzt gecheckt?
Oder ich muss noch, ich glaube, ich muss noch mal, ich glaube, ich muss noch mal rebooten.
Restart.
Über Containers geht kein Docker-Compose.
Ja, das ist, das ist LXC.
Das geht nur mit diesem komischen Jammel-Gedöns da.
Ich lege da aber jetzt mal was mit der leeren Datei an und gucke mal, wie das sich da editieren lässt.
Vielleicht kann man ja, nachdem man was angelegt hat, tatsächlich ein Git-Repo angeben.
Schauen wir mal.
Aber aktuell wird erstmal rebooted.
Booten-Islam.
Ich würde ja gerne auch mal Ulama drauf starten.
Und gucken.
Also Ulama.
Ich überlege gerade.
In einem Docker-Container vielleicht?
Ne, in der VM.
Wir starten Ulama in der VM.
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob halt diese
ob halt die
GPU überhaupt was bringt, ja
Ob das irgendwas
Ja, aber ich glaube
das iGPU Zeug, das macht halt
wirklich keinen Unterschied
Okay, das geht anscheinend noch nicht.
Ich will mal gucken, wie schnell
2, 3, 3, 4 Talkens pro Sekunde höchstens
Ja, denke ich auch
Aber just for fun, gucken wir mal
Wie hieß dieses
Mini-Model, was wir das letzte Mal ausprobiert haben
Zum Testen, weiß das noch jemand?
Wir hatten noch so ein kleines
Model zum Testen das letzte Mal
War das ein Mistral-Model?
Jetzt, das war ja nicht
Komm, wir klatschen das
Wir klatschen das auf den
Auf den Tunas
Auf das Tunas selbst drauf
Ne, komm, wir machen Container
Ja, wir haben noch, wir haben noch einen Container
Also, erst einmal hier nochmal
Discover Apps
Custom App
Ne, ne, ne, ne, Moment
Geh weg
Quen 3.5. Ich brauche irgendwas
Kleines. Ich habe so gut wie keinen RAM hier drauf.
Keckel.
Save.
Empty Compose File.
0w.
Okay, das
geht anscheinend nicht.
Okay.
Hat keinen Sinn.
Oh, Lama Models.
Ja, wir können einfach das da nehmen.
Einfach das da.
Gut, das hier, Lama 3.1.
Hier, guck, das ist 4,9.
Das ist top.
Das nehmen wir jetzt.
Achso, oh man, bin ich dumm, Alter.
Es gibt es wahrscheinlich auch nicht bei jemandem.
Okay, dann starten wir mal kurz unseren Container.
Wird schon entschieden.
Containers. Blub.
Was ich auch
blöd finde ist,
dass man hier
nicht die IP vom Container
sieht. Das ist auch ein bisschen verschenkt.
Weil so eine Übersicht
willst du ja immer mal ganz gerne haben.
117.
Okay.
So.
Install Olamar.
Einfach mal wieder random Sachen aus dem Internet.
S.
Achso, das ist
SH.
Einfach mal wieder random Sachen aus dem Internet
als Root
nach SH pipen.
Upt. Install.
ZSTD.
So macht man das.
Dass man auch schön
von Supply Chain Angriffen profitiert.
So und jetzt?
War das
Minus Minus Verbis oder so?
Was musste man an Ulama
hinten dran schreiben,
dass der einem die
Tokens pro Sekunde anzeigt?
Ulama
Verbis.
Ah ja, hier.
Genau.
Minus Minus Verbis, ja.
Aufmachine.
Also wie gesagt, ich tippe auch auf keine Ahnung.
Drei Tokens oder so die Sekunde.
Irgendwie super lahm.
Wie viel hatten wir nochmal auf dem Minis-Forum bekommen?
Das war echt ganz gut auf dem Minis-Forum.
13 oder so, gell?
Wart ihr auf der Arbeit von Axios betroffen?
Nicht, dass ich es mitbekommen hätte.
Äh.
Ja, wir haben keine Nvidia-GPU.
Hier, Ulama Run.
Ne, Moment, Moment.
Verbose.
So, wie viel RAM haben wir eigentlich frei?
Chat.
Warum habe ich so wenig frei?
Was ist das für ein Mist?
WTF?
Hat er die VM gestartet, der Depp?
Hat er meine VM gestartet vielleicht?
Nö.
Hä?
Was brauchen da so viel RAM?
Omega-Keckel.
Was ist das?
Naja.
Dann wird das nicht sonderlich schnell werden.
Die Apps.
Stimmt, ihr habt recht.
Ich werde die Apps alle stoppen.
ZFS-Cache.
Ja gut, dann sollte es ja wieder freigegeben werden.
Guck, der Container verbraucht ja kaum was.
Dann sollte es ja im Endeffekt auch wieder freigegeben werden gleich.
Gucken wir mal.
auf machen wahrscheinlich wird das wird das laden schon brauchen oder so gucken wir mal
bei der gelegenheit schauen wir auch gerade mal was für cpu auslastung hat wenn man da models lädt
Okay.
Äh, Ulama braucht jetzt einfach mal
100% CPU Last. Nice.
Okay, Model wird geladen.
Mal gucken, wie
lahm das ist.
Oh, da ist ein Shutdown. Okay.
Hallo.
Naja.
Okay, was ist das beste Twitch-Emote?
Ganz ehrlich, für so eine kleine, relativ schwachbrüstige, im Vergleich zu fetten AI-Kisten, Nasskiste,
ist das ganz in Ordnung.
Die Geschwindigkeit.
Ja, 6,7 Tonnen die Sekunde
ist echt nicht übel.
Ist echt in Ordnung.
Ne, das hatte keinen Sinn.
Das hier ist glaube ich das Wichtigste.
Oder?
Ich glaube, das ist das Wichtigste.
Evil Raid.
guck hier 5,74
ja
das geht
ohne Mist das geht echt
damit kannst du zwar nichts wirklich
so wo es auf
auf Response Zeit ankommt
anfangen
aber das ist in Ordnung
das geht klar
Also sowas wie Paperless
Einmal in der Nacht
Was drüber laufen lassen
Für ein paar Stunden
Ist damit vielleicht sogar möglich
Aber Spaß macht es wahrscheinlich nicht
Das ist wohl so
Ich würde jetzt gerne noch schnell Proxmox auf der Kiste installieren.
Einfach um zu wissen, ob die Proxmox-Installation ordentlich funktioniert.
Weil ich glaube, viele Leute möchten da auch Proxmox drauf verwenden.
Eher Minisforum, wenn man ein bisschen mehr Power haben will.
Ja.
das Ding ist
die Minisforums
Kiste die ich hab
die hat halt ne
äh
so ne semi gute
Netzwerkkarte
ähm ab und zu unerklärliche
NVMe SSD
Performance Einbrüche ab und zu
manchmal ist auch absolut top
ähm
und Minisforum
ist halt dafür bekannt keine Bios Updates
zugelesen. Was meine
Stonks machen, wollen sie euch mal gucken.
Ach, guck mal.
Ich guck mal, was meine Stonks
machen. Die sind bestimmt gefallen.
Moment hier. Stonks.
Gut, dass du sagst.
Ab und zu mal gucken. Schade.
Ja, die sind ein bisschen gefallen.
Knapp minus 2000 Euro.
F.
Na, dann würde ich sagen, ist jetzt Zeit, noch mehr einzukaufen.
Also, Stork ist ja ein bisschen runtergegangen.
Ja, es kommt auf jeden Fall noch was auf YouTube.
Aber erst, wenn ich wieder da Kopfhörer habe.
Ich werde nie aufhören, YouTube zu machen.
Tot ist der Kanal.
Der wird nie tot sein.
So.
Dann installieren wir jetzt schnell nochmal Proxmox drauf.
Und gucken, ob das...
Ich will einfach nur wissen, ob das glatt läuft.
Ähm.
Zack.
сятсятсятсят
сятсятсят
сят
Wie gesagt, der Kanal wird nie dämmen.
Immer mal wieder Videos geben.
Ich kann gerade halt nicht.
Gescheit.
So.
Proxmox gab es bei Netboot XYZ, glaube ich.
pxe boot netboot xyz
So, wo haben wir das?
Live-CDs? Wo steht Proxmox?
Ne?
Linux Network Installs
Proxmox
Ah, da ist es doch, Proxmox
VE 9.1
Sind wir nicht bei 9.2 schon?
Müssen wir dann nochmal updaten
Wobei, eigentlich ist es egal, müssen wir auch
Wir müssen gar nichts
Ich will ja einfach nur gucken, ob der Installer ordentlich funktioniert
Startet er jetzt den
GUI Installer etwa?
MonkaW GUI Installer
Du
Ich hoffe, 8 GB RAM reicht mit dem Installer im RAM.
Und dann, ja, das müsste Proxmox, Debian, Base, der Install, das braucht nicht viel.
Und, haben wir es?
monka monka es monka monka es es bootet
wie viel strom verbraucht das nas also wir haben das bios in den advanced modus versetzt haben dann
ein paar reddit empfohlene power consumption tweaks durchgeführt haben
power top das optimieren lassen und dann braucht die kiste eitel unbestückt nur
mit einer nvme ssd drin für das system ungefähr 18 watt
Das ist okay.
Das ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig gut.
Das ist aber auch nicht wahnsinnig schlecht.
Also es gibt schon auf jeden, also es gibt auf jeden massig Kisten, die deutlich weniger brauchen, ja.
Aber das ist okay.
Also es gibt genug Kisten, die brauchen unter 10 Watt Eidel.
Oder teilweise unter 8.
Was für Platten kommen da rein?
In die Kisten hier kommt gar nichts rein.
In das Minisforum NAS kommt 24TB Platten rein.
Eine habe ich schon.
Geschuckt habe ich die.
Acreege.
So, Hardware-Disk.
Jawohl.
Ich will aber ZFS machen.
ZFS, ZFS, RAID 0 muss man da glaube ich auswählen.
Disk Setup.
Do not use, do not use.
NVMe.
Advanced.
A-Shift.
12. Da kann ich mir immer nicht merken,
aber das wird schon passen.
Next. Country.
Germany.
Keyboard. Also wie gesagt,
der Proxmox-Installer ist wirklich sehr angenehm.
Next. Passwort.
123456.
Example.com.
Next.
Was?
123456789.
123 57 89 ip-adresse der box kriegt 2.51
hat der andere glaube ich auch gateway 50 dns server 50 ausnehmen next ach so ja ja und example
punkt kommen atlantic das ist die sehr gut dienen die netzwerkkarte jetzt auch der cp bekommen hat
Next, next, next, install.
Bam.
Wie gesagt, ich will damit das nächste großartige machen.
Ich will nur mal gucken, ob das sich ordentlich installieren lässt auf dem Nass.
Dann hau ich da ein iPerf oder so hinten drauf, um zu gucken, ob die 10-Geek-Netzwerkkarte damit auch ordentlich tut.
Aber muss.
Ich meine, das ist beides.
Das ist ein Debian drunter.
Und die Aquantia-Treiber sind wahrscheinlich jetzt auch nicht die neuesten im Kernel.
Die sind jetzt wahrscheinlich auch schon eine ganze Weile.
Weil wir es gerade davon hatten,
Chat, dass der
Realtek-Treiber richtig eklig ist.
Wollen wir mal gucken, wie der
Aquantia-Treiber ist.
Ähm, Drivers,
Net, Ethernet,
Aquantia,
Atlantic.
So.
Da haben wir schon mal,
das sieht schon mal anders aus.
Ja, C.
Ja.
Ups.
Guck mal hier, viel weniger Magic.
Ein bisschen Magic haben wir hier noch.
Aber guck, da hast du die Sachen benannt zwischendurch.
Da hast du benannt, was er macht.
Main C.
Guck mal, du hast sogar Kommentare.
If unlikely. What?
Was zum Teufel ist unlikely für eine Funktion?
Also guck, das hier ist ein Netzwerktreiber, den kann man lesen.
Guck, die haben ja auch ordentliche Inams, wo du gucken kannst, was Sache ist.
Den kann man lesen.
Ich verstehe den auch nicht, aber du hast zumindest die Chance, den zu verstehen.
und es sind nicht nur Magic Bites
wie beim Realtek-Treiber.
Guck, da ist jede Menge, das ist ja kein E-Nom,
das ist ein Define, okay.
Also das ist
ein anderes Beispiel,
wie man es auch machen kann.
Guck hier, schönes Tract.
Wave Review, was heißt?
Ja, also das ist die schönere Variante.
Oh, wir sind schon gestartet.
2.51
OXMOX
RISKY
ROOT 123456789
Bei meinem Passwort ist das auch egal.
Zack. Okay.
Nice, also das scheint zu funktionieren.
Dann gehen wir da mal drauf.
2.51
ROOT
PIX SSH
Irgendwie backt es gerade rum
Update
Was hat mein Proxmox für Schmerzen, Leute?
Ach, das sind diese Kack-Repos, die immer rumspacken
Wartet mal
Proxmenu
das ist normal wir können ich genau wir machen noch ein post install wir lassen
noch eins von diesen post install scripts laufen erst mal wieder random
sachen aus dem internet copy pasten so wie man es natürlich machen sollte
Post Install, Automated Post Install, yes.
So, jetzt haben wir unser Proxmox da auch noch auf dem aktuellen Stand.
Dann mache ich noch ein iPerf.
Dann muss ich was futtern, aber wenn ihr wollt, können wir zusammen futtern.
Dann hole ich mir das Essen hoch von Rechner und wir können noch irgendwelche Videos für eine Stunde oder so gucken.
C++ Flame Video. Wird mal Zeit.
Das wollte ich ja schon die ganze Zeit mal gucken. Also fertig gucken.
C++ Bad.
Dieses Video hier.
Zwei Stunden.
Zwei Stunden neun.
Was?
Fireship hat ein neues Video?
Fireship YouTube.
Aber wahrscheinlich
interessiert es mich nicht, weil es wieder ein AI-Video ist.
Das Library shouldn't be possible.
Das kenne ich.
Das ist das mit dem Textrendering, oder?
Das habe ich gesehen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das Firechip-Video dazu gesehen habe.
Glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube nicht.
Da hat irgendeiner Fontrendering verbessert für den Browser.
So wie ich das verstanden habe,
rendert der quasi die Sachen auf einem Canvas, was nicht angezeigt wird, guckt dort wie breit der Text ist
und kann das deswegen schon quasi die richtige Größe rendern, ohne den Text rendern zu müssen im HTML.
Ganz, ganz abgedrehtes Zeug wieder.
Do you want subscription banner? Yes.
Restart now.
No.
Yes.
Cancel.
Zack.
Uptinstall IPerf3.
No.
IPerf3-S.
So.
Und zwar...
Auf 51.
Hm.
Könnte das eventuell sogar was mit
Broxmog so zu tun haben
Dass wir so schlechte
Performance haben mit der Netzwerkkarte
Wobei jetzt ist die Performance vollkommen
Top
Ich hab nix gesagt
Die Performance ist richtig gut jetzt wieder
Das war initial mal irgendwie
Macht's das?
Ja, vielleicht doch keine so gute Idee.
Aber ist trotzdem deutlich schneller als die andere
Naja, viel viel konstanter auch und so
Warum das manchmal dann so lahm ist?
Vielleicht sollte ich Proxmox auf dem Minisforum auch nochmal neu installieren
und da iPerf machen.
Was meint ihr?
Ich glaube, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Also nicht jetzt.
Moe oder so.
Aber Proxmox-Funds
bin ich
zufrieden mit.
Power off.
Dann hole ich mir jetzt mal was zu futtern
gleich in 5 Minuten unten.
Also Fire Ship müssen wir nicht gucken.
Das ist doch...
Moment, der hat einfach aus seinem langen Video noch ein Best-of-Ding geschnitten oder so.
Ja, der hat aus seinem großen Video noch kleinere Videos geschnitten.
Für YouTube Shorts.
Eigentlich sehr High IQ Move.
Das ist doch auch KI generierte Readme, oder?
Mit den ganzen Emojis drin.
Post Install.
Gucken wir mal, was der da so alles treibt.
Available Optimizations.
Okay, du hast recht.
Der fummelt.
Der fummelt ganz schön viel an den Netzwerk-Config rum, da hast du aber recht.
Der fummelt aber da ganz schön viel in der Zwerg-Config rum.
Ich glaube, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, ich installiere wirklich mal Proxmox nochmal neu.
Wobei, nee, Schwachsinn, Schwachsinn.
Vergiss es.
Muss ich doch gar nicht.
Muss ich doch gar nicht, Leute.
Wir haben noch Arch installiert auf Minis Forum.
Und da war das doch das Gleiche mit der Netzwerkkarte.
Was wir aber nicht gemacht haben, ist Chat.
Das hätten wir vielleicht noch machen sollen.
Wir haben Arch Linux installiert, aber wir haben nicht den Realtek-Treiber da drauf mal ausprobiert.
Oh, das muss ich mir aufschreiben.
Das müssen wir auch nochmal ausprobieren.
Arch installieren und dann Realtek DKMS-Treiber.
Und dann mal gucken, wie der da performt.
Ah, das ist blöd von mir gewesen, dass ich das nicht gemacht habe.
Wobei, wir können das tatsächlich...
Das nächste Mal im nächsten Stream relativ easy ausprobieren.
Weil ich hab CacheOS ja immer noch drauf installiert auf der zweiten Platte.
Oder hab ich die schon wieder ins Raid gepackt?
Ich glaub nicht.
Braucht man nicht.
Weil ich faul bin, um das Subscription-Banner und die Repos und so wegzumachen.
Eigentlich braucht man kein Post-Install-Script.
Komplett für den Arsch.
Es ist sogar viel besser, wenn man es nicht macht.
besser man weiß was man macht und macht die dinger selbst oder baut sich selbst
irgendein skript mit den settings die man haben will anstatt blind irgendwelche
random skript zu hause mit ein auszuführen wo man nicht weiß was sie
machen
eigentlich richtig low iq dass das ausführen
Na ja, heute habe ich da keinen Kopf mehr für.
Ich bin jetzt viereinhalb Stunden lang.
Heute machen wir das nicht.
Jetzt gucken wir nochmal.
Haben wir dann irgendwas Schönes auf YouTube, was wir uns angucken können?
Wir müssen uns ja nicht unbedingt jetzt den vollen C++ Flame geben.
Ähm.
Was ist das?
Was soll es in dem Video jetzt gehen?
Ne, das ist nichts, was mich interessiert, glaube ich.
Ein Raspberry Pi, der analoges Telefon macht.
Das habe ich noch unbedingt gebraucht.
Was?
Äh.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was diese vier Zeilen bedeuten sollen.
Hahaha.
es schön dass du da bist mit hallo
jetzt zeigte take down your smart kameras warum warum weil meine kamera
Hex, ja, ja, bla bla.
Ist kein Problem.
Meine Kameras sind nicht in der Cloud.
Alle offline kommen nicht mal ins Internet
und du kommst doch nirgendswo dran.
Also, kein Problem.
Haben die Leute von der NASA
haben die eigentlich
ihre Outlook-Probleme
gelöst bekommen?
Die haben doch wohl Probleme mit
Outlook im Weltall. Das ist kein
Witz. Ich hab's auch für einen Witz gehalten.
Oder war das doch ein Witz? Ich glaube es war kein Witz, dass die Outlook Probleme im Weltall hatten.
Was ist denn das für ein Ding?
Wurde gelöst, okay.
Wenn ich das Wort Plates höre, muss ich immer an Plate Center denken. Beste.
Was ist so ein
Computermodul? Hier.
Für mich war das Peak Server.
IBM Play Center.
Peak Server Hardware.
Diese Dinger hier. Beste Leute.
Jetzt fliegst du weg dahinter.
Bei den Dingern konntest du nicht richtig stehen dahinter, so viel haben die gepustet.
Guck mal hier, Plate...
Plate Center Booting.
Das war für mich Peak Server Hardware.
IBM Plate Center.
Neuer Tag, neuer Tag.
Ja, aber wir haben es schon erledigt.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Der hat ein Playcenter daheim?
Warum das denn?
Wir haben die Dinger zu zweit.
Haben wir die ins Rack eingebaut, Leute.
Da hast du dir einen abgebrochen bei.
Da hast du dir richtig einen abgebrochen.
Ich muss mich nicht fragen, warum ich keins daheim habe.
Ich weiß, warum ich keins daheim habe.
Best Playcenter ever.
HS22, ja.
Die hatten damals schon 96 GB RAM.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Das ist 15 Jahre oder so her.
Das war richtig fett.
Könntest du dir heute gar nicht mehr leisten, so eine Ausstattung.
Ja, Blades and Blitzes, die Dinger waren schon echt nice.
Das war für mich echt
Geek-Server-Hardware.
Developers, Developers, Developers.
Gaben, was macht der hier?
Ja, also
ein Haus konntest du davon nicht kaufen.
Aber so ein HS23
Plate
oder ein HS22 Plate,
als die neu waren.
Das war schon ein Auto.
jetzt nicht das krasseste auto aber so ein einsteiger auto so ein bisschen kleineres
einsteiger oder was einsteiger einsteiger ist das falsche wort bei autos wie nennt man das
so kleinwagen mäßig sind schon hat es schon gekostet also die dinger waren damals irgendwie
bei 22.000 21.000 oder so 24.000 euro in dem dreh wenn ich das richtig im kopf habe in der
config.
Das war schon ordentlich.
Heute ist Freitag.
Wie viel haben wir die größte
Kiste bei euch auf der Arbeit, Max? Ich habe keine
Ahnung. Ich war ewig...
Also ich war letztens tatsächlich mal
in einem kleinen Rechenzentrum
dort, wo ich arbeite.
Aber ich... Wie gesagt, ich war schon seit
15 Jahren nicht mehr regelmäßig im Rechenzentrum.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was für Hardware
darunter ist.
Cloudkisten zählen für dich ja wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was so
die fettesten Hardware-Sachen sind, die wir da haben.
Wirklich, kein blassen Schimmer.
So, Chat, ich hole mir mal was zu essen.
Und dann gucken wir C++ Flame an.
Bin gleich wieder da.
BRB, wie man früher gesagt hat.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
genau rf programmer so sieht's aus manche haben damals auch reha geschrieben das
fand ich immer ganz abartig wir haben geschrieben
Also ich finde immer noch die, also in MMOs eine der besten Denglish-Abkürzungen war
Afklo.
Ich muss mal AFK aufs Klo.
Ich hätte ja gerne echt mal wieder
einen MMO, was weniger
Singleplayer
mit Leuten, die dir ab und zu über den Weg laufen ist
sondern mehr so
Multiplayer
halt
Multiplayer in
persistenter so Fantasy
Welt
wo man mit den anderen Leuten zusammen halt
Zeugs macht.
Irgendwas raiden, irgendwelche
Items farmen, irgendwelches
PvP.
So wie MMOs früher waren.
Da hätte ich mal wieder richtig Bock auf was Neues.
Quasi so eine
Chatbox
Game. Also
wo man halt auch mit den Leuten ein bisschen
labern muss.
Und sich koordinieren muss.
Und sowas.
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann mit World of Warcraft...
Also ich...
Das Einzige, was ich mit World of Warcraft anfangen kann, ist...
Bisschen zumindest Classic.
Ähm...
Das ist aber auch nicht so 100%ig meins.
Aber das geht auch noch klar.
Das geht auch noch klar, ja.
Das kann ich auch spielen.
Das ist schon okay.
So, Chat, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Wollen wir uns jetzt C++ Flame angucken?
Das Problem ist, wenn ich mir das C++ Flame Video angucke, dann kann ich nicht essen dabei.
Weil da muss ich laufend irgendwie reinquatschen.
Ich meine mit Leuten chatten, nicht labern.
In MMOs wurde ja gechattet.
Chat horse.
Mir hat chatten schon immer leichter gefallen, als mit irgendwelchen Leuten telefonieren.
Deswegen bin ich auch tatsächlich, was MMOs angeht und Group-Content ein bisschen hin und her gerissen.
Ja, wenn man das wirklich ernsthaft spielen will und den schwereren Content machen will, dann ist es schon besser und ist ein riesen Vorteil im Discord zu sein oder im Teamspeak.
Aber für den normalen Content, ich finde Chat einfach so viel angenehmer.
Du kannst nebenbei irgendwas aufhaben, irgendwas gucken, irgendwas fressen, irgendwie auf dem Handy mal kurz gucken und ab und zu schreibst du halt mal was in Chat.
Ich finde das viel angenehmer, als permanent die Leute am Labern zu haben und auf dem Ort zu haben.
Gibt es eigentlich wieder eine neue Eden Dark Season?
sieht nicht so aus jetzt auch mal wieder bock drauf
was gehen wir aber noch pre world of warcraft
doch kann ich sagen zumindest wenn du in der pvp spielst und ich rede jetzt nicht
von, wir rennen mit
80 bis 150 Leuten rum
gegen andere 80 bis 150 Leute.
Wenn du
mit
kleinen Gruppen bis zu 8 Mann
rumläufst,
dann wird mit dir der Boden aufgewischt,
wenn du nicht im Discord bist.
Also ich meine jetzt nicht deine Gruppe,
sondern die Gegner wischen mit dir den Boden auf.
Allein schon von der ganzen Kommunikation,
wer wo irgendwas macht,
wo Gegner sind,
auf wen man jetzt geht,
das kannst du fast verknicken.
Deswegen finde ich BG in Daok auch sehr
angenehm. Daok ist in die BG,
ähm, lädst ein paar
Leute ein, die du kennst und rennst halt im Zerg mit.
Battlefield 6?
Nö, hab ich auch nicht vor.
Und ich glaube,
aber das ist jetzt nur Hörensagen,
ich glaube, wenn du beispielsweise
World of Warcraft spielst und
dort, wie nennt sich das in World of Warcraft?
Mythic Instanzen oder so
machst?
also die die die die die höheren schwierigkeits kann da ist voice chat glaube ich auch komplett
muss kannst du vergessen ohne ohne voice chat rate ich jetzt mal ich habe es ja selbst nie
gemacht aber ich glaube nicht dass du da wirklich die die top high end sachen machen kannst ohne
voice chat es sei denn alle beteiligten haben das schon 300 mal gemacht und
wissen alles geht ohne ja aber die meisten haben noch sicherlich im
diskurse
Also die richtigen Grupps.
Brauchst du nicht, ja?
Okay.
Also ich habe von World of Warcraft
absolut keinen Plan.
Aber die ganzen
World First Clear
und sowas, die sind bestimmt
im Voice Chat, oder?
Hast du als alter Battlefield 3er
kein Interesse am ähnlichen Gameplay?
Ey, mich spricht Battlefield 6
nur zum Teil an.
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin...
Das, was ich bisher gesehen habe,
ist jetzt nicht so gewesen, wo ich gedacht habe, oh geil,
das strahlt für mich
so krass Battlefield aus, dass ich das jetzt
wieder spielen will. Also, ich hätte
schon mega Bock auf ein Game wie Battlefield 3.
Wenn ich dann aber schon höre,
sie haben irgendwie gefühlt die halben Entwickler
schon wieder entlassen. Es kommt alle
Schaltjahre mal eine neue Map und es
tut sich sonst nichts.
Habe ich schon wieder keinen Bock.
Also ich weiß nur von
Dark, Dark musst du eigentlich
wenn du halbwegs ernsthaft
PvP spielst,
im Discord sein.
Das klappt sonst kommunikationsmäßig einfach nicht.
Ach ja.
Sind OLEDs jetzt komplett unproblematisch?
Okay, das finde ich tatsächlich ganz spannend.
was gucken wir jetzt
ich bin hier auf einer
Preissuchmaschine
das Problem bei OLEDs
nur mal für Kacknoobs wie mich
und es mal so zusammenzufassen
war das Problem bei OLEDs nicht
dass die einbrennen
war das nicht das Hauptproblem
bei OLEDs
alles andere war doch bei OLEDs
mega nice
die reaktionszeit ist mega nice der blickwinkel ist mega nice schwarz also
wie nennt man das so dass das schwarz auch richtig schwarz ist es nice
ansonsten ist doch alles top
kontrast ist nice ja genau
ansonsten sieht die drei mit dem eis an exzellenz monitor an platz eins oder
Platz 2, OLED? Platz 3, OLED?
Platz 4, OLED? Ah ja, Platz 5 ist ohne OLED, zumindest im Namen.
Ah, okay, ist auch ein OLED.
Ja, okay.
Einen einzigen Monitor gibt es in den Top 10, der nicht OLED ist.
Und das liegt vermutlich auch nur daran, dass...
Ach, Monitor, ich dachte, ich bin jetzt mal Fernseher.
Mein nächster Monitor wird auf jeden Fall auch ein OLED.
Ich habe das letzte Mal schon überlegt, aber da war das noch nicht ganz so...
Ich habe jetzt einen 240-Hertz-Monitor.
Das nächste Mal hole ich mir einen 380 Hertz oder was sind die Dinger?
Ja doch, 380 sind die mittlerweile, ne?
380 Hertz OLED, bam.
Ich habe letzten sogar einen 720 Hertz gesehen.
Aber das konnte der glaube ich auch nur dann mit 720p oder so.
Mehr Hertz ist nie unnötig, besser.
überrascht war, wie populär OLED inzwischen geworden ist. Sind OLEDs jetzt tatsächlich
Mainstream? Hatten die nicht immer noch Probleme mit Einbrennen und mit zu niedriger Helligkeit
für so sonnendurchflutete Räume? Ja, das gucken wir uns jetzt alles mal an. Ich habe mir den für
mich am besten passenden OLED besorgt. Ich habe den ein halbes Jahr lang als Hauptmonitor intensiv
getestet, genau 646 Stunden lang. Außerdem zeige ich euch, ganz wichtig, wie ihr den für euch
passenden Monitor findet. Und da habe ich
wirklich sehr konkrete Tipps, die
ihr vielleicht noch nicht kennt.
Monitore gehören übrigens zu den Computerteilen,
die nicht teurer geworden sind
in den letzten Monaten. Interessiert mich tatsächlich
auch. Ich hätte tatsächlich Bock auf
einen neuen Monitor.
Ja, komm.
Nice. Bleib dran.
Liebe Hackerin, liebe... Ah, hallo?
Ja, aha, okay. Ja. Ne, kein KI.
Nein. Ne, ne. Ja.
Ja.
KI kann man bei der Hardware-Recherche auch immer ganz gut verwenden. Am besten natürlich welche,
die nicht eure Daten fürs Training verwendet. Da kommt Mammuth ins Spiel, unser Sponsored Website.
Hand auf Beschreibung, Erklärung, Ende. Wenn man ehrlich ist, Hardware kaufen ist ja eigentlich
erstmal vorbei, nachdem die Computerhersteller alle beschlossen haben, dass sie nur noch an KI
Rechenzentren liefern wollen und alle anderen völlig egal sind. Aber was ich festgestellt
gestellt habe, Monitore sind nicht teurer geworden. Und da trifft sich das ganz gut,
dass ich meinen 27 Zöller irgendwie zu klein und auch zu kontrastarm fand. So ein Ultra-Wide-Teil
wollte ich aber nicht haben, weil ich bei mir die zugegeben sehr spezifische Anwendung habe,
dass ich ständig Bildschirmaufnahmen für unsere 3003 Videos mache und unsere Videos sind halt im
Seitenverhältnis 16 zu 9 und nicht 21 zu 9. Okay, ja, ja, ja, man kann auch mit 21 zu 9 Monitoren
16 zu 9 Capture. Das bedeutet aber, dass ich da ständig rumkonfigurieren müsste und dazu
hat man da nicht Balken oder ist es da nicht gestreckt? So habe ich keine Lust.
Außerdem finde ich 16 zu 9 sowieso irgendwie ganz gut, weil es mein Sichtfeld ausfüllt und ich nicht
die ganze Zeit hin und her gucken muss. Aber hey, das ist mein Geschmack, kann bei euch alles total
anders aussehen. Ich bin auf jeden Fall auf geizhals.de gegangen und obwohl ich das schon
lange benutze, war ich wirklich überrascht, wie detailliert man da die Dinge filtern kann,
wenn man da so richtig reingeht. Und das ist jetzt eine ehrliche Aussage von mir, obwohl,
und jetzt Disclaimer, mein Arbeitgeber Heise Mehrheitsaktionär bei Geizheils ist. Übrigens
auch Alleingesellschaft dabei. Übrigens, wusstet ihr, dass Mindfactory auch zu Heise gehört
mittlerweile? Billiger.de und günstiger.de. Okay, über die Namen können wir nochmal sprechen. Die
populärste Preissuchmaschine hierzulande ist übrigens Idealo. Die gehört mehrheitlich dem
Axel Springer Konzern. Idealo kann man natürlich auch benutzen bei der Monitorsuche, aber ganz
ehrlich, Geizhals ist vor allem bei Technik Sachen viel detaillierter. Das sage ich als Keno,
nicht als Heise Mitarbeiter. Und ich finde auf jeden Fall auch, dass die Geizhals Website sehr
gut zu Heise und CT passt. Die verschwendet keine Energie auf Design. Funktion folgt Form. Ganz
wichtig. Dafür ist Geizhals, die Geizhals Webseite auch sehr flott. Super praktisch. Guck mal,
Ich klicke hier auf Monitore und dann gibt es da über 3000 Produkte, aber ich grenze das jetzt ein und klicke dann halt das an, was mir wichtig ist.
Also ich weiß, dass mir 27 Zoll zu klein sind.
Also 31,5 Zoll und maximal bis...
Mir?
Ganz ehrlich, mir würde 27 Zoll locker reichen.
Ich habe aktuell glaube ich 23 Zoll oder so.
Und da bin ich vollkommen fein damit.
Übrigens fein, damit fein sein, das ist auch so richtig dummes Dengelich, ja.
weil ich sitze halt hier auf dem Tisch, da ist nicht viel Platz zwischen Monitor und mir.
Wenn ich einen größeren Monitor hätte, würde ich gar nicht mehr alles sehen.
35,5 Zoll, weil mehr kriege ich nicht auf meinen Schreibtisch.
Und 16 zu 9 will ich auch, hatte ich am Anfang gesagt.
Also klicke ich das an und dann bleiben noch 384 Modelle übrig.
Das ist schon mal deutlich weniger.
Außerdem will ich 4K UHD Auflösung. Aha, nur noch 209.
Bildwiederholfrequenz habe ich jetzt keine extrem starke Meinung,
aber ich will glaube ich mehr als 60.
Also ab 120.
Und jetzt das Wichtigste.
Kein IPS oder VA.
Das ist alles LCD.
Nein, ich will ja OLED.
Zack.
Runter auf 46.
Ja, und dann muss ich erstmal runterscrollen, weil da erstmal so für mich eher unwichtige Sachen kommen.
Für mich dann aber wichtig der USB-C Teil.
Ich will da Laptops und andere Sachen über USB-C anschließen, die dann nicht nur geladen werden,
sondern ich auch Tastatur und so verwenden kann, die am Monitor hängen.
Also so klassische Dockingstation-Funktionen, halt ohne Dockingstation, nur mit dem Monitor.
Das Bild soll natürlich auch übertragen werden über USB-C.
Das ist für mich praktisch, weil ich sehr oft unterschiedliche Geräte teste.
Und so kann ich die mit einem Kabel anschließen und muss da nicht so ewig rumfummeln.
Ich klicke also hier auf Displayport, inklusive USB-C zweimal und Power Delivery.
Ab 65 Watt würde ich mal sagen.
Das reicht mir, um die Teile aufzuladen.
Und dann sind wir auf einmal schon bei 23 Geräten.
So, und jetzt wird es richtig interessant.
Das ist so ein Klassiker bei Displays und auch bei Notebooks.
Also ist mir schon öfter aufgefallen.
Ich checke dann ganz oft nicht, wo die Unterschiede bei so leicht unterschiedlichen Typbezeichnungen sind.
Also UXWRD.
Ja, man kann das gut vergleichen auf Geiz halt.
Ja, es klappt erstaunlich gut.
UXWRD versus UXWRD versus UXWRD.
Ich meine, das sind ja auch mal wieder Produktbezeichnungen aus der Hölle hier.
Ich meine, LS32FM100SUXEN.
Fuck, Alter, Samsung.
Aber auch hier ganz schön Acer Predator X32X5BMIIPHUZX.
Okay, ganz easy, ne?
Also wenn da jetzt ein Buchstabe anders ist, wie unterscheidet sich das Gerät dann?
Aber was man jetzt machen kann, und das ist in diesem Fall echt für mich das Killer-Feature,
also ihr klickt hier auf diese beiden Pfeile und dann wird das Gerät zur Vergleichsliste hinzugefügt.
hinzugefügt und dann klickt ihr alle an, die ihr vergleichen wollt, also für euch in die
engere Auswahl kommen.
Es wirkt ein bisschen wie Sellout für Geiz.
Und dann werden mir die Unterschiede gelb markiert.
Ja, super.
Und jetzt kann ich auch die Unterschiede sehen bei den leicht veränderten Typbezeichnungen.
Wie gesagt, funktioniert nicht nur bei Monitoren, funktioniert auch super mit Laptops unter
anderem und auch bei Fernsehern und bei allen möglichen Dingen.
Super praktisch.
Ja, und da ist mir dann auch aufgefallen, dass nur einer der Monitore, die hier bei
mir in der engeren Auswahl waren, über USB-C DisplayPort 2.1a unterstützt, was ich schon
sehr gerne hätte, weil es ist nicht garantiert, dass die älteren Standards 4K mit 120 Hertz ohne
DSC können. DSC, wenn ihr euch das jetzt fragt, das ist so eine theoretisch fürs Auge unsichtbare
Kompression, die aber manchmal Probleme macht. Zum Beispiel habe ich schon mal beobachtet,
wenn man mit Alt-Tab aus dem Spiel raus tappt und der Bildschirm dann ein paar Sekunden schwarz
wird also meistens ist dsc kein problem aber wenn ich es irgendwie vermeiden kann dann nehme ich
doch lieber displayport 21 a weil da geht es ohne kompression und deswegen habe ich mich dann am
ende für den msi mpg 322 u rxd entschieden ja gleich mal auf bestellt und beim auspacken kickt
hier direkt meine grobmotoriker panik ein wie fragil ist das ding bitte und sind ulec sowieso
So, ja, ich check, dass das nice aussieht, wenn es quasi keinen Rahmen gibt.
Aber beim Handling muss man da wirklich extrem aufpassen.
Auch so Fingerabdrücke sind sofort brutal zu sehen und müssen vorsichtig weggeputzt werden.
Das finde ich, sollte man wirklich immer sagen bei OLEDs.
Wenn ihr irgendwas richtig Robustes haben wollt, was man auch ein bisschen grob behandeln kann
und was ihr öfter von A nach B tragen wollt, dann sind vor allem so große OLEDs vielleicht nichts für euch.
Das ist wirklich oft sehr filigran alles.
Ist ja auch logisch, OLEDs brauchen halt keine Hintergrundbeleuchtung, weshalb die extrem dünn gebraucht werden.
Ja, da leuchten die Pixel selbst.
Das ist ja auch einer der Vorteile.
Und das ist meistens natürlich auch kein Problem, wenn ihr das irgendwo fest installieren wollt.
Aber ich sag das trotzdem einfach mal dazu, wenn ihr oft auf Lans oder so geht, dann vielleicht besser ein Monitor mit einem stepplichen Gehäuse.
Alter, Chad, auf einer Lan war ich, glaube ich, seit 25 Jahren nicht mehr oder so.
Gibt's das überhaupt noch?
lcd hier seht ihr hier deutlich den unterschied bei meinem alten lcd monitor so dass jetzt hier
zum gehäuse aber wie ist das bild denn jetzt und ja das ist super ich muss ehrlich sagen
dass das ein riesiger unterschied gegenüber meinem 4k ips lcd ist guck mal hier das sind
die beiden untereinander oben mein alter 27 zöller mit ips lcd und unten der 32 zöller mit oled ja gut
das sieht man da siehst du direkt dass hier halt vom kontrast der schwarz schwarz ist und da halt
hintergrundbeleuchtung das im endeffekt von nur abgedunkelt wird noch deutlich dass schwarz ist
halt schwarz und die farben kicken auch richtig rein aber wenn man die vorhänge aufzieht und die
sonne reinkommt dann sieht man auch das display spiegelt definitiv mehr als bei meinem alten
monitor das ist jetzt nicht so schön in hellen umgebung aber was ich dann doch erstaunlich fand
die helligkeit reichte auch bei dem oled für helle räume also wo die sonne reinknallt das sind hier
beide monitore bei voller helligkeit untereinander also geht schon aber aber so richtig spaß macht
der oled halt vor allem im dunklerer umgebung das muss man schon sagen und dafür lacht ihr
mich jetzt vermutlich aus mein alter monitor hatte maximal 60 hertz und ich dachte dass man auch nicht
unbedingt mehr braucht für so büroarbeit aber 220 240 hertz ist doch also das merkst du das merkst du
sogar auf dem Desktop.
Ihr habt das ja auch hier bei meiner Linux-Kiste, ne?
Wenn ich die umschalte,
oder ich hatte es ja am Anfang, konnte ich ja nicht mit mehr
als 60 Hertz capturen.
Wenn ich das nur mit 60 Hertz hatte,
das hat sich so...
Der Mauszeiger, der hat so richtige
Sprünge gemacht, ja? Und jetzt ist
das super weich und überhaupt keine Probleme.
Ihr seht es nicht so gut, weil ihr seht es
nur mit 48 FPS.
Aber wie ist das so weich? Oder auch
gerade wenn man...
Hier so ein bisschen was bewegliches hat oder so. Guck mal, wie weich das Fenster wobbelt hier.
Wie gesagt, ihr seht es nicht richtig gut, weil halt nur 48 FPS.
Ein Game Changer. Das habe ich also wirklich in dem Moment, wo ich den OLED angeschlossen habe.
Nicht in 120, ich wobble in 240 Hertz.
Ich habe sofort gemerkt und das Interessante ist, das ist nicht nur beim Gaming so, sondern das ist auch schon bei ganz normalen Sachen wie Fenster hin und her schieben, Maus bewegen.
Es ist einfach alles viel, viel, viel geschmeidiger und ich will da nicht mehr von weg.
Die Frage ist, ob man wirklich mehr als 120 Hertz braucht.
Mein Testmonitor hat jetzt 240 Hertz.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob man den Unterschied 120, 240, ob das so einen Riesenunterschied macht.
Also, ihr könnt mich vor den Monitor setzen zwischen 120 und 240.
Ich sag euch sofort, was der 240 Monitor ist.
Sofort.
Da muss ich einfach nur die Maus bewegen. Sofort.
Ob ich den Unterschied zwischen 240 und 380, oder 360 sind es denn, gell?
360 sind es, glaube ich.
Ob ich den noch so, ich würde behaupten, den merke ich auch noch.
Aber das ist schon dann ein bisschen schwieriger.
Auf der Arbeit?
Boah.
Keine Ahnung.
Habe ich nie nachgeguckt.
Ähm.
Wenn ich jetzt so überlege.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich 60.
Das Ding ist, es hat ja auch eine riesen Auflösung.
Es ist curved.
wahrscheinlich 60 hat er auf der Arbeit, würde ich jetzt mal drauf tippen, wenn ich mir so jetzt so recht überlege.
Sollen wir das mal detailliert testen? Also bis wann Menschen das überhaupt wahrnehmen können?
Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben, aber auf jeden Fall 120 Hertz, das will man schon haben.
Also ich zumindest.
Ja, okay, und was ich auch noch loben kann, ist die Blickwinkelabhängigkeit.
Die ist nämlich nicht vorhanden.
Auf der Arbeit schiebe ich wenig Fenster. Ich habe einen Terminal im Fullscreen.
Von allen Seiten super aus. Das ist bei guten LCDs zwar auch besser geworden, aber so gut wie OLED schwierig. Wir müssen aber natürlich jetzt noch zu den zwei OLED-Elefanten im Raum kommen und das ist zum ersten einmal die ungleichmäßige Pixelmatrix, beziehungsweise konkreter.
Und war der Stromverbrauch bei OLEDs nicht auch höher als bei LCD? Oder bringe ich das durcheinander?
Bei früheren OLEDs so eine gezackte Textdarstellung wahrgenommen,
beziehungsweise Farbsäume.
Das war auf jeden Fall bei älteren OLEDs.
Oder vielleicht sogar niedriger? Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Aber ganz ehrlich, könnt ihr jetzt das große Fass aufmachen?
Ich habe es jetzt irgendwie im Hinterkopf, dass irgendwas mit dem Stromverbrauch war.
Ich kann es euch erklären.
Aber bei dem OLED-Monitor hier ist das für mich kein Problem.
Obwohl die RGB-Subpixel nicht gleichmäßig angeordnet sind,
sondern ungleichmäßig.
bei der weniger blaue und rote Subpixel als grüne verwendet werden.
Das ist so, aber ich kann es nicht wahrnehmen.
Guck mal hier, das ist einmal Text auf dem LCD und das ist einmal Text auf dem OLED.
Also wenn ich mir einbilde, dann kann ich auf dem OLED so ganz leichte Farbsäume sehen.
Also in dieser Videoaufnahme, bloß im Auge, beim normalen Arbeiten nicht.
Aber ich kann mir das auch bei dem LCD einbilden, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich finde sogar, dass das Bild hier in dieser Aufnahme sogar bei den OLEDs ein bisschen gleichmäßiger aussieht.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist ganz dicht dran mit der Kamera.
Ihr seid ja mindestens 30 Zentimeter weg davon und dann nehme zumindest ich das alles nicht mehr wahr.
Deshalb ist das meines Erachtens kein Problem.
Wenn das für euch trotzdem ein Thema ist und ihr Angst davor habt, dass ihr das wahrnehmt,
dann könnt ihr auch einfach noch ein bisschen abwarten, denn sowohl Samsung als auch LG,
also die OLED-Panel-Hersteller, die haben beide angekündigt,
bei den kommenden Modellen die Subpixel klassisch anzuordnen, also in der RGB-Matrix,
beziehungsweise gleichmäßiger.
Ich habe einen Heiser-Artikel dazu verlinkt, wenn euch das interessiert.
Aber wie gesagt, meines Erachtens macht auch die aktuelle Generation, zumindest bei dieser hohen Auflösung, ganz wichtig, kein Problem.
Also bei geringeren Auflösungen und bei den 21 zu 9, da kann man es vielleicht wahrnehmen, aber hier bei meinem 4K-Monitor eben nicht.
Und jetzt der zweite Elefant im Raum, Einbrennen.
Ein Riesenthema, immer schon, und zwar gerade bei für Büroarbeiten genutzten Monitoren.
Ich sage mal, ich schreibe ständig Texte in Nextcloud Office.
Checkt ihr, checkt ihr, ich habe nicht Microsoft Word gesagt.
Ja, und da habe ich das Benz so oft.
Word ist ja, also ganz ehrlich,
Office-Programme sind das
so
overusedeste, was es so gibt.
Das Einzige, was ich, wie gesagt,
was ich ab und zu verwende, ist PowerPoint,
weil halt alle auf PowerPoint-Präsentationen
stehen. Ansonsten, wenn ich was schreiben
muss, schreibe ich das in Markdown. Fertig.
Das reicht.
Briefe und so,
Markdown.
an der gleichen Stelle und dann habt ihr natürlich auch immer
die Icons vom User Interface an der
gleichen Stelle. Wo es natürlich schwierig
wird, ist wenn du Text anordnen willst
und sowas. Also wenn ich jetzt einen Brief
schreiben würde, der so ins Fenster
muss oder so. Ja,
okay, aber für solche Sachen
bin ich eh faul.
Da habe ich mittlerweile ein
Labeldrucker, wo ich Adressen
und sowas
raushaue.
Das war ja immer so gefährliches Territory bei OLED.
MSI hat aber in dem Monitor, den ich getestet habe, etliche Funktionen eingebaut, die das verhindern sollen.
Zum Beispiel Pixel-Shift.
Damit nicht immer die gleichen Pixel die gleichen Farben darstellen müssen,
wird das Bild alle zwei Minuten um wenige Pixel verschoben.
Hatte ich die ganze Zeit an, ist mir nicht einmal aufgefallen.
Das gleiche gilt für Static Screen Detection, Taskbar Detection und Logo Detection.
Der Monitor prüft die ganze Zeit, ob es irgendwelche Bildelemente gibt,
die sich lange Zeit nicht verändern und dimmt die dann etwas runter.
Kann man alles abstellen? Habe ich nicht abgestellt.
Hatte ich alles auf Standard? Habe ich nicht einmal wahrgenommen.
Jetzt kommt was, was mir aufgefallen ist, nämlich OLED Care 2.0.
Sobald der Monitor vier Stunden gelaufen ist und in den Standby geht,
dann läuft so eine Pixel-Auffrischung, wobei dann so Helligkeitsunterschiede ausgeglichen werden.
Das heißt, wenn einzelne Pixel viel heller geleuchtet haben als andere,
werden die anderen auch gealtert, eben damit gleichmäßig altert.
Also angenommen, ihr habt acht Stunden an dem Bildschirm gearbeitet und das Teil schaltet sich dann ab, weil ihr Feierabend macht, dann wird nach ungefähr zehn Minuten automatisch dieser OLED-Care-Modus aktiviert und dieser Prozess dauert so eine Viertelstunde immer und in vielen Fällen kriegt ihr das also gar nicht mit, weil es passiert nur, wenn der Monitor in Standby geht.
Aber wenn ihr während dieses Prozesses wiederkommt und an den Rechner geht, dann wundert ihr euch womöglich, warum der Monitor auf einmal kein Bild anzeigt.
Ihr könnt an den Einschaltknopf drücken und dann wird der Prozess abgebrochen.
Ihr könnt wieder ganz normal daran arbeiten oder spielen.
Das lässt sich viermal abbrechen.
Dann beim fünften Mal, wenn ihr es beim fünften Mal abbrechen wollt, dann zwingt euch der Monitor dazu.
Dann müsst ihr also diese Viertelstunde warten.
Ich hatte das in meinem halben Jahr mit diesem Monitor nicht einmal, dass ich das nicht abbrechen konnte.
Also ich hatte das schon, dass der in diesen Care-Modus gegangen bin, als ich mal wiedergekommen bin oder so.
Aber dann habe ich es immer manuell abgebrochen.
Und dann hat er den Care-Modus halt gemacht, wenn ich dann das nächste Mal Pause gemacht habe.
Also diese viermal beziehungsweise fünfmal habe ich nicht einmal ausgekostet, dass ich da diesen Modus anschalten musste.
Ich habe mir übrigens am Ende des halben Jahres auch ganz genau mit einfarbigen Bildschirminhalten angeguckt, ob ich ein Brennmuster sehen kann.
Und ich habe keine gefunden.
Wie gesagt, nach 640 Betriebsstunden und laut Monitor 82 Auffrischungsvorgängen.
Aber offenbar auch nach längerer Zeit passieren keine schlimmeren Dinge.
Also der YouTube-Channel Monitors Unboxed hat das nämlich zwei Jahre lang ausprobiert.
Interessanterweise mit dem Vorgängermodell von dem, was ich hier getestet habe, dem MPG 321 statt MPG 322.
Die benutzen beide das gleiche von Samsung hergestellte OLED-Panel.
Und ja, da kann man bei genauem Hingucken was erkennen.
Richtig viel ist das...
Da musst du aber wirklich sehr genau hingucken.
Was ich ganz interessant finde, obwohl da 659 dieser Auffrischungsvorgänge durchgelaufen sind,
ist die SDR-Maximalhelligkeit nur von 243 auf 238 Nits runtergegangen.
Das ist ziemlich wenig.
Also für mich heißt das, Einbrennen macht mir persönlich keine großen Sorgen.
Gibt bei MSI auch noch eine 3-Jahres-Einbrennen-Garantie.
Ich könnte jetzt auch nochmal alle kleinen, kleinen Gaming-Funktionen hier durchhächeln,
Aber da habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine Lust zu, weil da sind die meisten auch eher quatschig.
Also vor allem die Bildverbesserungsfunktionen, die sehen meiner Meinung nach gruselig aus.
Okay, man kann eine sogenannte Optiksfunktion anschalten.
Smart Crosshair, da kriegst du einen Punkt in der Mitte vom Bildschirm angezeigt.
Der mittlere Teil des Bildschirms so vergrößert, hilft womöglich bei Shootern.
Ja, habe ich nicht verwendet. Wir Profis brauchen das nicht, ne? Wisst ihr?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Was ich aber wirklich oberpraktisch finde, die USB-Hub-Funktion.
Man hat halt einmal eine USB-C Buchse plus zweimal USB-A und einmal USB-B und da kann ich dann einfach zum Beispiel mein Notebook über ein USB-C Kabel anschließen und dann wird das aufgeladen, das Bild wird übertragen, mein Audio Interface ist verbunden, was am Monitor hängt mit Mikrofon und Lautsprechern und meine Tastatur, die auch über USB am Monitor hängt auch.
Will ich einen anderen Rechner benutzen, stöpsel ich einfach mein eines USB-C Kabel um und zack, fertig.
Das geht übrigens auch unter...
Ja, das ist schon praktisch, das stimmt.
Linux hier zum Beispiel mit meinem Framework Desktop hier und das auch übrigens problemlos mit 240 Hertz.
Kurioserweise geht das mit meiner Linux-Maschine hier sogar besser als mit meinem Apple MacBook Air M2.
Das kann nämlich nur 120 Hertz, aber das liegt nicht am Monitor, sondern an Apple.
Für 240 Hertz braucht man Pro, Max oder Ultra bei Apple.
Ja, okay.
Mein, weil es Apple ist, Fazit.
Wäre das kein Testgerät, was ich zurückschicken muss, würde ich den Monitor auf jeden Fall behalten.
Ich muss mir mal überlegen, ob ich jetzt wirklich 850 Euro auf den Tisch legen will dafür.
Aber mir hat das alles schon sehr gut gefallen.
Also das super tintige Schwarz, die 32 Zoll Größe, die USB-C Hub-Funktion, vor allem die 240 Hertz.
Ich habe echt Probleme jetzt wieder zurück zu meinem alten 27 Zöller mit 60 Hertz zu gehen.
Die Sachen, die ich für mich kritisieren würde, sind an erster Stelle ganz klar die krass spiegelnde Oberfläche.
Die stört mich interessanterweise am meisten von...
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, da bin ich auch ein bisschen allergisch dagegen.
Bei allen Kritikpunkten, also deutlich mehr als die etwas geringere Helligkeit.
Die reicht für mich auch, wenn die Sonne richtig reinknallt, aber die Spiegelung, die nervt mich.
Ja, und ich finde auch etwas beunruhigend, dass das Teil so papierdünn ist und ich hätte echt Angst, wenn ich damit umziehen müsste.
Ja, okay, ist vielleicht eine Spezialangst bei mir.
Ja, und diese Zwangspausen mit der OLED-Auffrischung, das ist so ein Mini-Ärgernis, was mich letztendlich nicht so richtig nervt, weil das kann man ja eben viermal abbrechen, bis man dazu gezwungen wird, diese Viertelstunde zu warten und das habe ich bei mir immer hingekriegt.
Also klar, wenn ihr jetzt so Leute seid, die irgendwie 30 Stunden am Stück gamen oder so, aber also normalen Nutzungszyklen sollte das eigentlich immer passen, dass das dann gemacht wird, wenn ihr den Monitor gerade nicht benutzt.
Achso, der Monitor hat übrigens auch keinen Lüfter, falls euch das noch interessiert. Da gibt es ja manchmal Geräte, die manchmal so unangenehme Geräusche machen. Ist hier nicht der Fall. Ja, am Ende muss man sich halt einfach selbst überlegen, ob man sich so einen Luxusmonitor gönnen will. Es ist ja alles super individuell. Gibt natürlich auch gute Monitore.
Aber, Chatge,
ähm, hier jetzt, wo man da,
wo man da echtes,
Leute richtiges Schwarz sehen,
ja, ist das nicht
prinzipbedingt bei einem
OLED automatisches
echtes Schwarz?
Weil,
du hast ja bei einem OLED quasi
keine Hintergrundbeleuchtung, die dann nur
im Endeffekt ausgeschaltet
oder nicht ausgeschaltet, ausgeschaltet,
geblockt wird, wie bei einem LCD.
sondern da leuchten ja die einzelnen Pixel.
Das heißt im Endeffekt,
der ist halt aus.
Also das muss ja doch eigentlich
so ein richtiger Schwarz sein.
Ja.
Die Kiste macht ganz guten Eindruck.
Ich behalte die aber nicht.
Die kriegt der Max, der Modge-Max.
Ja.
Also ich denke mal, mein nächster Bildschirm wird höchstwahrscheinlich auch ein OLED.
prophezeie ich jetzt einfach mal.
Chat, sehr schön, dass ihr alle mit dabei wart,
was wir unser Nassstelz heute gemacht haben.
Nächsten Stream geht's weiter mit,
ich hab mir aufgeschrieben,
nochmal im Minisforum die Realtek-Karte unter Arch Linux testen,
Proxmox nochmal neu installieren
mit
ohne dieses
Post Install.
Das ist aber kein wirklicher
Stream-Content, der alleine
vier Stunden geht oder so.
Das heißt, da müssen wir irgendwas anderes machen
und das machen wir nebenbei.
Müssen wir mal schauen, was dann angesagt ist.
Vielleicht machen wir ja dann,
was haben wir denn hier, Stream-Themen,
U-Creeners LEDs ansteuern.
Das interessiert mich tatsächlich.
und nächsten Stream mache ich dann auch die Kamera an,
also nicht um mich zu leaken oder so
und wir gucken uns das Ukraine-NAS mal so an,
von innen und schauen mal, wie das so aufgebaut ist.
Vielleicht machen wir auch einen Proggers-Stream noch dazwischen.
Wir haben auf jeden Fall jetzt die nächsten Tage massig Zeit.
Samstag wird gestreamt, Sonntag wird gestreamt,
Montag wird wahrscheinlich gestreamt.
Ich weiß, ich labere immer viel, wenn der Tag lang ist,
dann strebe ich nicht, aber ist zumindest der Plan.
Ich hätte ja eigentlich auch gestern,
also vorgestern habe ich gestreamt,
ich hätte ja eigentlich auch vorgestern gestreamt,
aber da konnte ich nicht.
Vorgestern war ich hier daheim am Rechner,
dann wollte ich noch einen Backup-Restore auf der Arbeit schnell,
weil mich einer angeschrieben hat in Teams.
Dann habe ich den Backup-Restore-Prozess angestoßen,
bricht ab.
Fuck, was da schon wird.
Du warst da, ich habe dich im Chat gesehen.
Abgebrochen.
dann nochmal neu gestartet,
dann lief's, aber wieder abgebrochen
zwischendurch. Und dann hab ich bis
18 Uhr oder so da rumgemacht
und da hab ich dann nochmal neu gestartet und hab bis
19 Uhr 16 immer wieder reingeguckt,
bis das Backup dann durch war.
Dann hab ich mir gedacht, okay, 19 Uhr 16
muss ich auch nochmal anfangen zu streamen, wenn ich spätestens
19 Uhr 40 oder so rum wieder off muss.
Das hat ja keinen Sinn.
Aber schön, dass ihr alle dabei wart.
Wer noch nicht gefollowt hat, ich freu mich über jedes Follow.
Natürlich auch über jeden. Stop.
Schön, dass ihr am Start wart.
Chatgear.
Und wir sehen uns bis nächstes Mal.
Macht's gut.
See you.